hello everybody Welcome to the July 2021
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast where we take questions from
patreon supporters of mindscape so if
you're not a patreon supporter
that's okay you're permitted to not be
patreon supporter but it's way more fun
and fulfilling in your life if you are
you can go to patreon.com
Sean M Carroll uh to sign up one dollar
per week or whatever it is to support
the podcast and you get to ask AMA
questions and then I answer them and
eventually everyone gets to listen sadly
not so sadly for me but sadly for the
AMA there are so many people and so many
good questions that I can't answer all
of them so I was asking anything but I
don't necessarily answer everything
sorry about that I do try to get a
representative sample right so if there
are themes that keep appearing I'm going
to try to at least answer someone's
question in that theme and I think you
know we've hit the point now where
there's so many questions that I'm
probably answering less than half so
really don't feel bad if your question
is not being answered it's not you it's
me as I said before I try to pick out
the questions where it's not only a good
question but something where I in
particular have something interesting to
say about it I will say you know I like
to give advice to people who want to
know how to get their questions answered
you know we say in the instructions
shorter questions are preferred I know
that some people seem to find that a
difficult piece of advice to take
seriously but really if you want to get
your question answered shorter questions
uh definitely do help you have that
happen it's not enough you can ask a
short question that doesn't get answered
but it definitely helps me say oh yes I
could answer this in a very brief period
also shout out to the patreon supporters
who suggested that we finally get a
merch store here at mindscape selling
T-shirts and mugs and things like that
so we've set up one on T public you can
find a link to it on the mindscape
webpage which is
preposterousuniverse.com podcast on the
right hand side there's a little link to
t-shirts mugs and more got some designs
there maybe more will be coming in the
future who knows but anyway you want a
sticker for your laptop that says
mindscape or you know maybe you want
your mask to have the core theory
equation on it there's the place to go
so with that let's go
[Music]
Eric Chen says what's your take on
Pascal's wager do you think there is a
simple explanation for why the argument
fails and if so do you think you have a
satisfactory account of how to make
decisions do ethics when infinities are
at stake so for those of you who don't
know you know to be honest I'm not going
to get this exactly right Pascal's wager
but the basic idea is look you know if
God exists
and God wants you to worship Him and
promises you infinite Time
Eternity of pleasure in heaven right
then it's worth almost anything uh to
get that if it's a possible thing even
if you think that God isn't very likely
in your prior the benefits of believing
him and worshiping him worshiping him uh
apparently are so great that we should
just do it even there's a one percent
chance times infinity reward right you
should go for it so I think that there's
two reasons I'm probably butchering that
by the way because I haven't looked it
up recently but that's the basic gist of
the idea
um and I think there's two things going
on one is kind of trivial and one is a
little bit more profound or difficult
the trivial thing is you know you could
say that kind of thing about all sorts
of different propositions with very very
different outcomes right I mean there's
a chance that God exists and would be
really annoyed if you believed in him in
him were worshiped him for the wrong
reason sins and those reasons might
include Pascal's wager and therefore God
would send you to hell for eternal
torment if you believed him for that
reason so that would be an argument to
not do it and all these arguments are a
little bit silly because you know how do
you actually decide what the entire set
of things are how do we decide which
religion to be if this is the kind of
argument that we're trying to follow so
just out of the gate I think that
Pascal's wager is not a very good
argument at all
there is as Eric you say in your
question a more interesting sub question
here which is the infinity question
right if you believe that more generally
there's some kind of argument for
maximizing something utility or reward
or likelihood of success or whatever and
there's something that is unlikely but
it's then multiplied by Infinity how do
you deal with that I mean it seems to
sort of pin the needle to you should
definitely take this seriously even
though apriari it's very unlikely and
you know I think that that's an argument
for not taking these Infinities
seriously you know I think this is not
what you're asking but this is one of
the reasons why heaven and hell are just
kind of silly as Concepts right I mean
it's the human inability to distinguish
between infinity and a very big number
you know we can imagine being happy or
being sad being rewarded or being uh
tortured for a brief period of time even
for a relatively long period of time on
human scales so we just say what if it
were infinite right what if that went
for eternity we don't sit back and ask
whether that makes any sense like could
you really even be happy for eternity
like this is is the idea of Heaven a
sensible concept to a human being
um I doubt it personally I don't even
think it is something that makes sense
and of course a real religious believer
would be well yes you know your human
capabilities here on Earth are not up to
the task of comprehending the
magnificence of heaven and maybe that's
true but then that means I can't
evaluate how seriously to take it here
if I'm that if that's the question I'm
asking myself so I do think that in
other contexts these questions of
dealing with infinity are subtle and I'm
not an expert on how to do it in this
context I just think that it's kind of a
silly uh proposition you're being forced
to consider in Pascal's wager
Daniel westwater says given that there's
more evidence for Galaxies without Dark
Matter do you think it would be possible
for the universe to exist without it and
what would it look like if so so there's
two things going on here also one is the
straightforward answer to your question
which is sure the universe could exist
without dark matter I mean maybe you
have something more specific in mind
than the existence of the universe like
the existence of the universe doesn't
care if there's dark matter or not you
could have a universe that had other
stuff in it or no stuff at all
um as far as we know at least it might
look different I mean maybe what you
mean is that the Universe would look
sufficiently different without dark
matter that stars or galaxies wouldn't
form and then maybe you wouldn't have
life and there'd be some anthropic
argument against that kind of universe I
mean that's that's possible we can
certainly imagine
arguments like that and um
and people have made arguments like that
in fact in the case of dark matter it's
a little weak you know I I because I
think what would actually be the case if
you didn't have dark matter I mean sorry
to back up a little bit the idea is that
um dark matter has no you know
restorative Force when it becomes
condensed into a region so dark matter
falls into a region under its
gravitational pull and there's no heat
or pressure pushing it back like there
is with ordinary matter whereas there's
also no stickiness or dissipation
um so if you had nothing but dark matter
in the universe Dark Matter would sort
of Clump together a little bit but not
too much because the Dark Matter
particles just go right through each
other when they begin to Clump together
on the other hand ordinary matter also
clumps together a little bit but not too
much because it clumps together but then
it heats up and pushes apart
so in some sense it's helpful to have
both dark matter and ordinary matter
working together so in the real world it
might have helped the formation of early
stars that we have dark matter in our
universe but that becomes a quantitative
question right how much did it help so
you don't need that many stars in the
universe to have one available for Life
forming right so even if you might say
well maybe there would only be one one
thousandth of the number of stars in the
universe if there were in Dark Matter
that's still plenty to make life and
things like that as far as I know anyway
so I'm skeptical of those anthropic
arguments also but the real reason I
wanted to answer this question or to
address this question is because I do
think there's an interesting point to be
made here that people sometimes miss
when we say as you said there's been
news lately if I'm getting it right
about finding galaxies that don't have
dark matter in them and of course in
certain circles whether or not dark
matter exists send the role it plays in
cosmological model building is a little
bit sticky so what I wanted to emphasize
is the counter-intuitive fact that
finding evidence for Galaxies without
dark matter in them is evidence for dark
matter
now why would that be true why would
finding the absence of dark matter be
evidenced for Dark Matter well the
answer is the alternative to dark matter
is something going on with gravity right
uh something some misunderstanding that
we have and how gravity works on large
scales when you get Galaxy sized things
but the thing about that hypothesis that
something is going on with gravity is
that it's pretty Universal right if
you're saying that the stuff of the
universe is just the stuff we see and
know about the ordinary matter the stars
and gas and dust and we don't understand
exactly how its gravitational field
arises but it arises from that stuff
then you have no matter what your theory
of gravity is
an immediate prediction that all
clusters of similar kinds of stuff
similar amounts of stuff will have the
same gravitational field because that's
that visible stuff that is creating the
gravitational field whereas if your
theory is well there's both ordinary
matter and dark matter then the Dynamics
of galaxies and sub galaxies and
clusters and things like that can be
such that you have two equal sized
collections of stars one of which has
dark matter associated with it one of
which doesn't
so that dark matter hypothesis even
though usually the amount of dark matter
it tracks in some weak sense the amount
of ordinary matter it has that extra
degree of Freedom that lets you explain
the existence of galaxies without dark
matter and therefore just ordinary
gravitational Dynamics in a way that a
theory that just modifies gravity
wouldn't let you do so the evidence for
Galaxies without dark matter is evidence
that dark matter is on the right track
Andre Dino says in your latest podcast
with John preskull you touch upon the
possibility that physical space and
distances between objects are emergent
phenomena arising from quantum
entanglement
you say the following it's not the
entanglement between you and me that
gives us the distance it's the
entanglement between visible degrees of
freedom in the space between us which is
a little bit hard to visualize can you
expand on this uh well I can try you
know I did write a book something deeply
hidden in which I talk about not only
many worlds quantum mechanics but also
the emergence of space-time
part of the difficulty of this idea is
that it is just a difficult idea you
know we're asking you to grasp some
purely abstract things you know I'm not
saying that space time is made of little
pixels or atoms or anything tangible
like that it's just made of abstract
quantum mechanical degrees of freedom
that has have entanglemented between
them it's hard to visualize it's hard to
wrap your brain around or to get your uh
hands on it in some sense so the idea is
that there's a quantum mechanical wave
function that can be expressed as
quantum mechanical degrees of freedom
with different amounts of entanglement
between them and the different amounts
of entanglement knit together to form a
more or less smooth three-dimensional
space time so the amount of entanglement
between these invisible space-time
degrees of freedom
um
has a very specific geometric structure
that fits nicely together to form a
smooth manifold now the huge question
and there are some other questions in
the AMA that I cut out because they were
a little bit redundant with this one so
consider this an answer
the huge question is
even if the entanglement between these
degrees of freedom can be like distances
in space or space time does that mean
that they are distances in space or
space-time well good question you know I
don't know that is one of the things
that we're trying to understand when you
say there's a distance between objects
in space or in space time for that
matter you have some operational notion
in mind about what that means what
you're saying is that it takes a certain
amount of time to get there if you go at
a certain velocity or you know signals
travel between this place and this place
in a certain way and so what you need is
a dynamical theory of traveling right
distances don't mean anything really
until you can travel from one point to
another
and so what you have to say is that the
entanglement structure of these abstract
degrees of freedom has an effect on the
propagation speed of signals in this
emergent space time and there's some
hints that something like that might
actually be true and we're on the right
track but I would say we're very far
from completely spelling it out so to
add to the difficulty that all this is
very abstract and hard to visualize is
the difficulty that we're not there yet
it's a very preliminary idea we don't
have the the full picture in mind so I
can't really tell you much more than
that sorry
Richard Riley says you told listeners a
couple months ago that you won't be
renewing your research Professor
contract at Caltech and will focus
instead on your podcast patreon YouTube
work and your other writing plus your
Santa Fe and Student Activity are you
concerned that not being fully in the
mix of top research University will make
you drift away from the center of the
physics cosmology world no matter what
else you may be doing so there's two
things to say about that one is prior to
there's a prior question here you know I
think either I am not clear or sometimes
people jump ahead of what I say to to
extrapolate beyond what I say so it is
not true that I am uh leaving Caltech to
focus instead on podcast patreon YouTube
that's not true what I meant to say and
I may or may not have actually said this
is the fact that uh I am doing well with
the podcast and with patreon and things
like that gives me the freedom to
contemplate doing something like that
I'm not at all
um uh devoted to doing it yet I don't
know uh my my future options are quite
up in the air and in fact uh you know
the the possibility that I am that I do
land at a university as a professor is
pretty high there's plenty of universe
not plenty there are universities who
you know are in touch let's put it that
way and would like to have me there and
I I need to think about how best to
maximize the work I want to do
um and so I don't know what that will be
yet you know um so to get into the
actual that's the Preamble the actual
question is a very good one right you
know what is the benefit versus
disadvantage of sticking around top
research University I may think there
are clear benefits and then there are
also disadvantages and so you have to
weigh them
a clear benefit is that you're
surrounded by other really smart people
doing interesting things right that's
the single biggest benefit
um there's sort of sub benefits to that
you have graduate students or post docs
uh you can teach and that can be
inspiring
um all but the most important thing is
that you're in a network of people uh
who can both give you ideas and also act
as reality checks on the ideas that you
have uh I I think that
overall if your goal was to be a
productive uh scholar intellectual
researcher
having that network of people to talk to
is just super duper crucially important
one way or the other so being at a
university is the most straightforward
way to have that uh there's another way
I can imagine having that by sort of
bouncing around right speaks uh
part-time at a place like Santa Fe visit
other places I'm spending this fall
visiting Harvard for example
um so I could easily imagine you know
being a gentleman researcher scholar uh
bouncing around from place to place
visiting places mixing it up with people
and the freedom to do that would be
provided by the fact that I don't need
to earn a living as a university
Professor if that's the direction I go
to
also there's sort of more down to earth
benefits of having institutional
affiliation
having graduate students being able to
hire postdocs apply for Grants is a much
easier thing to do and things like that
that part would uh that that really
means that the Santa Fe
um uh part-time faculty position that I
have uh it would be very useful if that
were the route that I decided to take
those those sorts of things become much
more possible and at the same time that
on the on the flip side I should say
there are disadvantages to having a
university position it's work right you
gotta teach and you got to be on
committees uh and you're you know my
Caltech position in particular which was
a research professorship since my
research interests have shifted a lot
and they don't really overlap with the
people I'm affiliated with at Caltech So
Much Anymore to be less of a good fit
you know again I what I said before is I
love Caltech nothing against Caltech
it's just not as good a fit for me as it
once was
um so I think these are good concerns
and you know I certainly it's certainly
easier now to imagine being completely
independent because you have the
internet right you can listen in on
talks you can like the other great
benefit that you used to have from being
at a university is you could go to
seminars right seminars in colloquia or
workshops that were nearby uh people
would come through and you could talk to
them some of that is ameliorated by the
fact that
a lot of these things are online these
days right uh see there's a there's a
kind of connection that doesn't require
that physical closeness but still you
know as anyone who's actually
participated in this knows whether it's
a workshop or conference or just your
day-to-day job a lot of the useful
interactions with colleagues happen at
lunch or at coffee or just you know
sitting around talking not necessarily
in a formal context of asking questions
at a seminar or something like that so
I'm a very big believer in the benefits
of being at an institution like that
it's just a complicated question how to
you know exactly balance things in a
particular way especially you know for
someone like me for a lot of people you
know who are who just fit very very
naturally into a certain Department
doing a certain kind of research and
that's exactly where they're happiest
it's not much of a competition that's
obviously the right thing to do for
someone like me who really values the
interdisciplinary kinds of things the
ability to say well well this month I'm
doing physics next month I'm doing
philosophy maybe someday I'll do
economics or biophysics or something
like that the freedom is very very
helpful so it's a it's an important set
of considerations to keep in mind
okay now I'm going to group some
questions together and you know I don't
think I'm going to give a very profound
answer to any of them but there were a
few of them so I think that you know
that boosts the chances of me answering
the question when there are related
questions and they're about art so Anita
tomasik says I wonder if there's any
tendency among theoretical physicists
who prefer abstract art to figurative
art
Chris says what are your views on Art
what is it what is its purpose how does
it fit into the world view is there
anything deep about it or is it just a
pleasurable activity like eating a tasty
meal and Lana salame says who are your
who are some of your favorite artists
out there whether it was in the Fine
Arts music film literature even comedy
um
so I don't I don't think that I have in
any sense a deeply thought out theory of
art I'm a big fan of Art and I take art
in this case not to just be painting or
sculpture or what are traditionally
called the Fine Arts but artistic things
uh so music film literature even comedy
as as Lana says all these count I think
in what we what we would what I'm
classifying as art for purposes of this
discussion
um you know I think that art is
important you know Chris says is there
anything deep about it or is it just a
pleasurable activity like eating a tasty
meal you know I think that eating a
tasty meal can be pretty deep you know I
think this is one of the pleasures of
life I think that that's all you did was
eat tasty meals uh if that's the only
pleasurable thing you did that would end
up being pretty shallow uh just because
it's kind of one thing over and over
again and different kinds of artistic
Expressions do have different amounts of
depth to them right you know I love
popular music but a three-minute pop
song can't quite have the level of depth
and complexity that an opera can I don't
think that gives an opera any intrinsic
objective superiority but it gives it a
different kind of experience and you
know likewise tasty meals are good but
if that's your only artistic experience
then you're missing out on the
literature and music and and visual Arts
kinds of perspectives so I think that
the there's no I'm not you know you
shouldn't be surprised if you know that
I'm not a moral realist to learn that
I'm not uh an aesthetic realist either
I don't believe in the objective
superiority of different works of art I
think that the important thing about art
is its relationship to the experiencer
of the art different kinds of people
experience different works of art in
different ways and if one person whether
it's me or someone else sees or
experiences a work of art and is deeply
affected by it whether it's by getting
pleasure from it or being provoked to
contemplate things in a new way or just
feeling some
um ineffable feeling of transcendence
then that is completely valid even if
someone else doesn't feel the same thing
at all so I try very hard not to
disparage works of art that I am
individually not very much into even if
other people are you know I think that
uh discussions yeah there's an
interesting philosophy problem here
because
we tend we judge things and then when we
judge things uh we tend to attribute
objective truth to our judgments but in
the case of art I truly think we
shouldn't you know even if you're
reviewing uh if you're a restaurant
critic or a music critic or an art
critic or whatever it is in my mind much
more useful for someone like that to
talk about the experience in a
non-objectively judgmental way right you
know if you like this then you'll like
that like so many things I meant I made
this comment on Twitter a few months ago
I guess about book reviews uh maybe it
wasn't book reviews in particular but
reviews of anything book reviews movie
reviews Etc there are so many reviews
that say you know this thing this object
this action this uh cultural product was
a good example of X but I wasn't in the
mood for X I wanted y therefore one star
and this is enormously frustrating you
know someone who's written books and I
can imagine it's just as frustrating for
someone who writes movies or produces
movies right you know this movie is very
depressing I was in the mood for a
comedy I didn't like it you know just
just say it's a comedy you know just or
just say it's it's depressing you know
and maybe someone's going to be in the
mood for that and I think that would be
the right kind of art criticism one that
really illuminated the different
possible ways that a work of art could
influence you and then let people react
to them in their individual ways is
there any tendency among theoretical
physicists to prefer abstract art to
figurative art I don't think so you know
I think that theoretical physicists
um have different attitudes towards art
some physicists are are pretty uh down
to earth about it right they want a
picture of something on the wall others
yet absolutely do prefer abstract art so
I think it's an interesting question I
don't have any data that would lead me
to say or at least I haven't uh
contemplated the question in a
sufficiently systematic way to actually
say whether there's a preference one way
or the other that is more tilted for
theoretical physicists than for other
people sorry about that who are some of
my favorite artists out there you know
when it comes to
um the Fine Arts these days I'm I'm I
just can't name names some of my best
friends actually are fine artists you
know here in La some of our very good
friends are painters
um and I love it but
um I I don't have any knowledge of the
field as a whole it's a whole huge world
right
I do like abstract art I like 20th
century art very very much but I also
like you know the older art so you know
going to an art museum is generally a
positive experience for me no matter
what kind of specialty it is I do like
Beauty in my art you know I I wanted to
have some aesthetic sense uh you know I
think one of the failure modes of art
usually although not always because not
everything uh is the you can't make
these predictions objectively but for me
um whenever a painter starts including
words
text into their art it always makes it
worse for me because the visual
experience
opens itself up into different kinds of
thoughts in different ways that might
impact one differently depending on you
know the time of day or whatever the
mood you're in whereas just putting a
word there is just such a blunt
instrument as far as I am concerned you
know I love words in in their own
context in the case context of
literature but you can only put a few
words onto a painting or whatever and
usually
it acts to constrict and narrow the
experience for me personally so
[Music]
um
I I started saying that because I'm
trying to explain you know what kinds of
artists I like when I go to
um uh museums or something like that so
look if it's Rembrandt or Michelangelo
love them they were amazing Raphael Etc
also you know Picasso Kandinsky I have a
Kandinsky t-shirt that I got when I was
looking over things on uh T public when
I was setting up my own t-shirt store uh
brilliant Kandinsky t-shirt
um I love you know the abstract
expressionists uh Mark rothko Jackson
Pollock
um Louise Bourgeois with these amazing
sculptures so I like lots of different
things and I can't even pinpoint and
many of these people are not alive
because I'm not up hip on the
Contemporary Art scene sorry about that
Manuel Bevan says in a 2014 World
Science Festival debate on quantum
mechanics you said something akin to if
a grw turned out to be true I would
probably retire from physics you wrote
jrw but it's grw uh gerardi ramini and
Weber uh this is a theory of quantum
mechanics in which wave functions
collapse spontaneously all by themselves
and so sorry Manuel is asking do you
still think that today if yes could you
elaborate on why a little more than you
did at the time so to be clear
um uh that was a joke not necessarily
retire from physics in fact it's almost
a private joke that I probably shouldn't
have said out loud because it's a uh an
allusion to Joe palchinski telling me
years ago like Circa 1997 or six that if
they found the cosmodial constant to be
non-zero he would retire from physics
because his reasoning was that the only
good explanation for it is the anthropic
principle the anthropic the anthropic
principle very ugly and dislikable so he
would retire it was just a joke when he
was saying it we did find the
cosmological constant he didn't retire
and we joked about that so the point is
just to emphasize the fact that you know
we physicists want to find out the truth
we want to find out how the world really
is right and then you're going to work
to understand whatever that truth
happens to be but we're also human
beings and we have preferences we have
things that ahead of time we would
consider to be more elegant solutions to
certain problems so
I think that the idea that wave
functions just sort of randomly collapse
um with a with a strong Arrow of time
they collapse in One Direction time but
they don't anti-collapse and it's
exactly tuned to be frequent enough to
explain our the our experience of the
macroscopic world but infrequent enough
not to show up in experiments that we've
already done ah that just seems to be uh
asking a lot of it just seems to be very
awkward okay so I don't like it and I
think that there is a much better
explanation right there on the table but
um I'm not going to retire from physics
even if it turns out to be true I would
suspect this may or may not be true but
I would suspect that if it turns out to
be true there's a more elegant beautiful
thing underlying that that will be
remaining to be found
mikolaj Salvo says I've recently come
across an old Nautilus article that
contrasted Neil deGrasse Tyson and Sam
Harris as representatives of two very
different but characteristic attitudes
of public intellectuals one is the very
opinionated the edgier the better stands
and the other could be called the
educator never taking sides or definite
positions my question is what do you
think about the role and
responsibilities of public thinkers in
our society and do you really think
there is such a spectrum and if so where
would you actually where would you
ideally want to be on it and where do
you think you actually are on this
spectrum so I want to remove this an
excellent question and I mean it was so
it's such a good question went to
restrain what I want to say about it I
could talk for a long time
but I want to remove Neil deGrasse Tyson
and Sam Harris from the question because
as soon as you name individual names
then you know they're fans or there are
critics and they talk about those people
and I don't care about that I want to
talk about the underlying idea
um so because you know we all debate
there's a long going debate about how to
be a good public intellectual actual
what that means whether that you know
every era says that the public
intellectual is dying Etc and others
will hold up their favorites okay so
it's an important uh debate worth having
I do not think that this particular
um division into edgy and educating uh
captures what it means to be public
knowledgeable in fact I would say that
these neither one of these categories
really is what I think of as public
intellectual so
let me explain what I mean by
intellectual in this context you know
intellectual doesn't mean intelligent
you can be intelligent but not
intellectual or you can mean an
intellectual and all not all that
intelligent really and an intellectual
is someone who is characterized by in my
mind and people can disagree and it's a
word who cares about the definition but
what I mean by it is someone who seeks
truth as the highest value they want to
find out what things are true what how
the world actually works and this can be
contrasted you know the obvious contrast
is with people who just kind of get
along right like you know they they
don't work too hard to understand how
the world as it is but you know they
have a pretty good view and they're
going to get through the day right I
mean that's most people in in the world
but there's another
um very important category that I don't
want to downgrade in importance which is
activists right an activist has a goal
and that goal might not be the same as
the truth right I mean the goal might be
a very good goal feed the hungry right
cure diseases uh you know fix the
political system in some way these are
very good goals and when you have these
goals if that's your highest goal that
can get in the way of the goal of
figuring out the truth and telling it
you would like to think and it's
probably often true that these goals are
in linement but not always right like if
you're if your view of how to make real
change in the world is to lead a
movement
whether it's being a politician running
for office or just you know being the
head of some more informal Coalition you
might come to the conclusion that
talking certain ways saying certain
things making certain uh activities and
so forth is more important than just
telling the truth or that there are some
things that are true that you don't want
to make public right I mean because they
get in the way of your goal so I'm not
disparaging that activists are important
in the world but it's not me and it's
not an intellectual the intellectual is
going to say look I'm going to tell you
what the truth is I'm going to try to
figure out the truth uh and no matter
what the implications are for what
happens in the world which is why you
know informally I have a policy here on
mindscape that I don't invite active
politicians onto the show someone who
was a politician and is now retired
maybe okay
um but once you're a politician your
goals are a little bit different than
discovering the truth and I I I will
stand up for the importance of politics
all the time and I'm pro-politics but
it's a different thing than being
intellectual so intellectuals are ones
who care about the truth and even I mean
maybe you could add to that people who
sort of have a process of finding out
the truth right like not just they care
about it passively but they care about
it actively they're you know taking
steps to understand the world better
okay and a public intellectual is one
who does that in public you know who
does that in full view of the world most
intellectuals are not public
and again that's fine like I don't want
much intellectuals to be public frankly
some of them are sort of a turn off in
the ways that they would talk about
things and there's no necessary
connection between finding the truth and
talking about the truth out loud in
front of an audience
um I think both are important but I
think they're different so I think
there's room for people who are
educators
um but that's different than being a
public intellectual you know an educator
is someone who says okay here are some
things we've figured out I'm going to
explain them to you I'm going to teach
you I'm going to be pedagogical about it
this is an incredibly important thing to
do right
um in some way this is journalism right
all of Journalism is okay there are some
true things I'm going to explain them to
you right but to me that's not quite
being an intellectual because an
intellectual saying you know we don't
know what the truth is yet we're trying
to find it so we're working in this
process to learn about the truth to
consider different hypotheses to make
arguments the real difference to me
between an intellectual and an educator
is that an educator is basically hanging
on to things we all more or less agree
are right at least you know the people
who are more or less in the mainstream
agree these things are right you know
human beings are causing global warming
the Earth is round right we evolve from
other species these kinds of things not
everyone sadly agrees our right but
there is pretty much a consensus whereas
an intellectual is working at you know
we're not sure what is the right
interpretation of quantum mechanics I
can't pretend just to be a disinterested
educator where I talk about the right
interpretation of quantum mechanics I I
need to say on the one hand we don't
know yet there are people who disagree
and acknowledge that and put that front
and center and on the other hand
I want to say but here's why I think
this one is true right so an educator
would say here are what people say about
the interpretations of quantum mechanics
an intellectual would add and here's why
I think this one is true which means
that intellectuals can be wrong
sometimes
um but it's a slight but I think
crucially important difference you know
the in your question or in this you're
quoting from this Nautilus article I
guess you're you're glossing the idea
being educator as saying never taking
sides or definite positions I think it's
a slightly unfair way of saying it I
mean educators are saying look there's a
lot of stuff we know about the world
that's interesting and important we're
going to try to share it that's a very
very valuable important thing to do it's
just a slightly different thing than the
intellectual engaged in an argument
right intellectuals are out there on the
boundary between what we know and what
we don't know trying to figure out what
is going on and the thing is that this
active of being intellectual being
devoted to the truth and working out
what the truth is making arguments
listening to other people's arguments
responding to them and so forth
there's a tension there with the idea
being public right it's not completely
opposed to it but it's not completely
aligned to it either because let's face
it uh you're not that much of a public
intellectual if no one's listening to
you right I mean you can call yourself a
public intellectual because you're out
there talking but there's a difference
between talking in a crowd in a town
square with a crowd gathered around you
versus Talking the same talk in the
middle of an empty field where no one's
listening right so to be a public
intellectual implies that you want
people to listen to you and you have
some success in getting them to listen
to you and there you get into the
question of you know the strategies or
the issue of the strategies for engaging
the public and getting them interested
and Gathering a big audience might also
not be aligned with the strategy of
telling the truth and this is where the
edginess comes in uh the idea not just
of edginess but of contrarianism them uh
you know of being a heretic being
radical uh to me all of these ideas
being a contrary and being edgy being
radical these are anti-intellectual
ideas that are very fundamental level
not because you should never be
contrarian or be a heretic or be radical
or be edgy but to valorize those things
is not to valorize finding the truth
right sometimes the truth is
conventional sometimes the truth is the
middle of the road you have to be open
to saying well you know maybe people are
right and when people are right explain
why they're right you know I was invited
to write a short piece for one of these
edited volumes that John Brockman used
to put together John Brockman is the
purveyor of the edge website and every
year he would have a question Center
that he would make into a book so the
question was one year what have you
changed your mind about and I explained
in my little short essay like two
paragraphs literally when I was younger
let's say in college I did valorize
being a heretic uh you know going
against the system fighting the man and
so my little changing mind essay was
being a heretic is hard work because
it's not good to just be a heretic for
the sake of being a heretic uh you have
to be a heretic because there's some
individual case where you think it's
worth going against the conventional
wisdom and uh so I I did change my mind
about that and I'm still willing to go
against the conventional wisdom but I'm
much more reluctant to do it because I
understand that there is a sort of
romance to it an attraction to it for
that reason both individually and for
the purposes of gathering an audience
um that is dangerous to the value of
being intellectual which is what I
actually value if your first goal is
being correct that's different than
having your first goal being edgy I
remember when
somewhere on the internet someone
mentioned that they had started
listening my podcast but they stopped
listening and went to other podcasts
because they were edgier and you know
with all due respect my immediate
response was good riddance like you're
not the audience I'm looking for if what
you're looking for is edginess my
audience I'm hoping is in it for the
truth and we don't always know what the
truth is which is why I will on the
podcast try to have people I disagree
with
but it's all part of the journey to find
to the truth and sometimes the truth
will be in the minority the radical view
sometimes it will be in the majority and
just go along and getting that balance
right is difficult so you know and and
anyway I think that uh public
intellectuals are crucially important
because I think that it's more than just
educating it's it's
exhibiting the process of trying to
figure out the truth uh in the case of
questions that can be very very hard and
that's messy you'll be wrong sometimes
you'll talk to people who you disagree
with but you know I want to talk to
people who I can engage with and I want
to sort of set an example for
constructive engagement between people
who disagree uh in different ways and uh
you know some people are not gonna like
that it's not gonna be some people's
thing and you know furthermore I have my
own idiosyncratic things that I care
about you know I am willing to be a bit
more technical in the weeds Etc than uh
many other people who uh in science
communication anyway and so that limits
the audience that I'm going to get in
some ways but that's okay because it's
still a pretty sizable audience right
like there are people I can reach with
things like the biggest ideas in the
universe or many of the episodes of this
podcast that I think want a little bit
more than they usually get uh in the
discourse and you know they're not in it
for the Cheap Thrills they really want
to hear uh the truth and the truth is
thrilling enough in in my view so I can
carve out a niche I'm never going to be
you know the super duper famous
um uh public intellectual science
Communicator or whatever but I think my
people appreciate what I am trying to do
and that's what is very rewarding for me
okay sorry if that was too long but you
know you pressed a button there
John Perry says taking on board strands
of various podcasts what chances do you
give to democracy winning out as the
optimum model for national government
given the increasing economic dominance
and military power of countries like
China and the level of digital
monitoring of individuals Etc they are
rapidly being able to achieve
um you know this is asking me in some
sense to predict the future right what
chances do I give to democracy winning
out and I'm very bad at predicting the
future that's one of the things I will
acknowledge is is not my area not my
expertise
um and furthermore I think it's probably
misguided to imagine there is such a an
idea as winning out when it comes to
being the optimal model Optimum model
for national government I think that
what we will see here I just said I'm
bad at making predictions and I'm about
to make a prediction but it's kind of
the milk toasty prediction uh my
prediction is that we'll continue to see
many different models
um that the equilibrium around the world
is that there will be some democracies
some authoritarian things some socialist
things some more radical different
experiments and different kinds of
government and so on what we can hope is
to change the balance between these
different kinds of things
um I do think that uh you know China in
some ways in many ways is that a very
natural world-leading country right it's
a huge country technologically advanced
speaks a Common Language and they have a
system of government that is very well
adapted to rapidly doing things right
you know there's it's Central planning
it's It's ability to make choices and
have them implemented very very quickly
but of course that same organization has
huge
um
disadvantages as well you know we talked
with Henry Farrell a little bit about
the fact that simply when it comes to
solving social problems there's a case
to be made that democracy is a better
solution finder than authoritarian
systems are
um but also you know there are a set of
values that go together that both go
into progress whether it's technological
or scientific progress or social or
moral progress uh and democracy right
and Henry and I didn't talk about this
but I mean this is more like if
democracy is a good problem-solving
measure then that's a benefit yes as a
bonus that's a spin-off as far as I'm
concerned what matters to me about
democracy is that it gives it puts power
in the hand of individual people and
that power helps unleash their
creativity right
um the even though science and and
politics are two very different things
the underlying values of allowing people
to try different things to be creative
to go against the grain sometimes are
very very important both for Democratic
politics and for experimental
theoretical Sciences right so there's a
a huge disadvantage that any
authoritarian Society puts themselves at
in a world where scientific and
technological uh progress are important
you know China is a big economy they're
very very good at making t-shirts uh and
things like that they're not as good as
we are here in the United States or in
Europe at scientific progress at least
not right now
maybe they will be but I think that part
of it is the spirit of you know letting
people be rebellious a little bit goes
goes hand in hand with the spirit of
scientific advancement right uh you know
anyone who thinks that there is some
luck step scientific establishment that
is working behind the scenes to squelch
their ideas has never been to a physics
seminar and listened to people asking
questions people are not in lockstep
people like to disagree that's important
that's you know part of the of the
creativity so I mean all I'm adding up
to is I don't know I don't know what's
going to win out uh there's a lot that
goes in to these things and a lot of
them are random a lot of them are
unpredictable so uh I like democracy I
hope it wins more places than it loses
but I can't be too sanguine about those
things
John T says many podcasts often include
scientists as guests to speak on
controversial topics but the term
scientist is vague anyone can claim to
be a scientist so as a layperson
listening to podcasts with scientist
guests how can I distinguish their
credibility to speak with genuine
Authority what heuristics can we use to
weight these opinions and protect
ourselves against the fallacy of appeals
to Authority well you know I
the appealing to Authority is a fallacy
but it is not useless
it's complicated and I think this is the
most important first step in answering
this question which is a very good
question is that it's complicated so you
use the word heuristics trying to use
the right one to use rather than
clear-cut algorithm you know when you
have people with different
expertises and different credentials
saying things that you yourself are not
an expert in who to believe who to trust
whose opinions to weight in different
ways is a very hard question and I think
that it is completely valid to
um weight people you know not 100 or not
zero percent right to give medium-sized
weights to a lot of different things but
there are things that matter more so I
think I've I've said things like this
before you know Julia gallif when she
was on the podcast she and I talked
about this
um
if someone is
and world renowned expert in precisely
the thing they're talking about count
them more than someone who is not that's
kind of obvious that's not really very
helpful but what does it mean to be a
world renowned expert it means more than
just you know you got a degree look you
know I went to grad school I have a PhD
I know other people who got phds not all
of them are super sharp to be honest
some of them are are brilliant some of
them are not but it's a start you know
someone with a PhD in economics you
should count more in their opinions
about economics than someone without any
phds at all or any special expertise in
economics that's pretty obvious to do
but someone can claim to be an expert
and maybe even have a PhD but if you
want to get more into the weeds what
have they accomplished what have they
done have they written papers have they
uh you know changed the field by having
some good ideas that later turned out to
be valid what is their track record
right this is the sort of second order
questions you can be asking yourself
um I think you correctly uh maybe allude
to the idea that if you have a PhD in
economics and are propounding on
politics or biology or the environment
and who cares about your PhD in
economics right I mean that's not what
what's really going to give you
expertise in this field so you have to
care about where their expertise comes
from or where their credentials actually
come from
um and finally you know
people can be absolutely insightful and
correct about ideas where they are not
credentialed experts so don't discount
people entirely just because they're not
experts in the field but weigh their
words carefully that's why this is a
hard thing to do again what is their
track record in other areas you know if
you're not a PhD in physics but you're
propounding on physics what's your track
record what have you gotten right in the
past I'm completely willing to to
believe that there are people out there
who don't have phds in physics yet have
really interesting things to say about
it but I also know for a fact there are
people with and without phds in physics
who say lots of lots of nonsense about
it so it's just a matter of you know
keeping your bearings and uh not taking
anyone too seriously if you don't know
what their background and track record
is and even if their track record is
great they could be messing up this time
so you know and I know that's a wishy
washy answer but that's the best you can
do right if there's a bunch of people I
guess sorry there is one other thing
which is crucially important which I
which I take for granted sometimes
when people do Proclaim things okay when
they say you know I think X is true
um regardless of their credentials or
their track record the way they say it
and the arguments they give in favor of
it can also be used as a measure of how
seriously to take them in particular
uh the short version of this is
what is there what is the evidence that
they're giving you that they appreciate
why they might be wrong that they
understand the counter arguments to it
right if they are just straw Manning the
counter arguments or if they're just
sort of snarky and sarcastic or if they
show no sign that they even know what
the counter arguments are then you
should discount what they're saying
compared to people who go I know what
you're thinking you're going to think
it's not true because of this but here's
why it's true anyway right and and this
kind of
um uh technique is just as true for
research papers in the technical
literature in the professional
literature as it is for people
expounding on podcasts and things like
that when people know why they might be
wrong it's much more worth uh listening
to what they're trying to say because
you can you can think that those people
have thought through what the different
arguments are rather than just following
love with one point of view and stating
it
okay Alexander Cordova says when
discussing quantum mechanics the example
that is always used is the electron
however it's also stated that everything
is quantum in nature at a small enough
scale do protons neutrons have wave
functions as well uh sure everything has
wave functions that's the easy part let
me just explain a little bit about why
the electron is always used as the
example it's sort of a combination of
two things one is the electron is as far
as we know Elementary it is not made of
other particles so protons and neutrons
are made of quarks and gluons right so
that just makes things a little bit
fuzzier when you talk about protons and
neutrons it's actually perfectly okay to
in some circumstances treat protons and
neutrons as fundamental particles in
other circumstances it's not right you
have to take into account that internal
structure so it becomes more complicated
whereas electrons as far as we know just
are fundamental particles so that
complication doesn't get in the way the
other is a electrons are the lightest
charged particles in nature they're the
lightest particles that have electric
charge electrons and positrons which are
the anti-particles so what that means is
that since electromagnetism is really
the force of nature that makes everyday
world go uh electrons are doing most of
the work right electrons are easy to
manipulate electricity is mostly the
motion of electrons because electrons
are lighter than protons and neutrons
you know in principle electrons going
left is equivalent to protons going
right but it cause it create it requires
a lot more energy to get protons going
right than electrons going left so in
practice when you have electricity going
down a wire the electrons are doing
almost all the work so that's why
they're used as the examples in quantum
mechanics it's easy to manipulate
electrons compared to protons or
neutrons but everything has a wave
function don't worry about that
Paul cousin or kuzan says Tebow Giro a
French YouTuber recently did an
experiment on his philosophy Channel
Moss your Phi or fee I don't know how
French people pronounce the Greek letter
Phi
I don't know how Greeks pronounce the
Greek letter Phi for that matter uh he
surveyed 12 000 of his viewers with
carefully corrected thought experiments
about Free Will and morality as an
example of an interesting and somewhat
surprising result around 80 percent were
intuitive compatibilists what do you
think about the idea of experimental
philosophy
um you know I don't think it's
philosophy I think it's an interesting
thing to do but it's a more like you're
learning about psychology you're not
learning about uh philosophy you know
I'd like to think that ideas and
philosophy whether it's free will
compatiblism or anything else stand and
fall on the reasons for them not on a
poll not on a popularity contest I do
think that anti-free will people
sometimes fall into the Trap of saying
well you know this or that I mean maybe
Pro compatible with free will people too
I I don't know but anyway people
sometimes fall into the Trap of saying
um that's not what the people really
have in mind when you say free will
okay I don't know what the people have
in mind like that's not an important
consideration for me I'm just trying to
get the most useful vocabulary to
discuss the world I want to be right and
I want to sort of figure out how best to
characterize the fact that human beings
make decisions okay I find talking about
Free Will for that purpose is perfectly
valid if you don't that's fine and I
honestly couldn't care less what the
majority of people have in mind as long
as we can be clear in fact my strategy
it is not it is completely failed so far
but the strategy I'm going to keep
trying to plug away at is whenever
someone really wants to have a
discussion about free will I'm going to
say you know I tried this with Sam
Harris it didn't work with him either
I'm going to say I'm happy to do that as
long as we never use the phrase free
will
because as soon as you use the phrase
free will you have this incredibly long
tedious boring and completely pointless
conversation about what do you mean by
Free Will so just don't use that phrase
if you can't agree on what it means just
don't use it use what words would
actually convey the meaning that you
have and I'm perfectly happy to do that
all right Connor Scott says
I know the Schrodinger equation doesn't
predict wave function collapse but it
definitely predicts wave function
branching sorry does it definitively
predict wave function branching in the
case where there is no collapse is that
something everyone can agree on
um there are so few things that everyone
can agree on in this game they can agree
on what the Schrodinger equation
predicts in terms of given some wave
function and given some hamiltonian what
does the Schrodinger equation say that
wave function evolves into
but you use the word branching in your
question so for example if you have an
electron that's in a superposition of
spin up and spin down and you run it
through Stern gerlock experiment where
there's a detector and an environment
and so forth everyone agrees that the
wave function of the universe if all it
does is obey the Schrodinger equation
would evolve into a part
that says the electron would spin up it
was measured to be spin up and the
environment noticed that plus a part
that said the electron would spin down
the detector measured it to be spin down
and the environment noticed that
I can't promise you that everyone is
going to be happy to call those two
parts of the wave function branches
there's an argument that goes into
saying there's a reason why we should
call this branches that has to do with
decoherence and the independence of the
future evolution of these two parts of
the wave function the fact they won't
interfere with each other Etc but
everyone agrees that the Schrodinger
equation predicts that that's what a
wave function should look like that's
why people who believe the um Copenhagen
interpretation or something like that
don't accept the Schrodinger equation to
describe Quantum measurements because
they don't believe in those two parts of
the wave function still surviving that
measurement event
Julian Reef or reif reif says Carlo
ravelli wrote in wrote The Following
about many world's interpretation in his
new book helgoland it is not enough to
know the wave function and Schrodinger's
equation in order to Define and use
quantum theory we need to specify an
algebra of observables otherwise we
cannot calculate anything and there is
no relation with the phenomena of our
experience the role of this algebra of
observables which is extremely clear in
other interpretations is not at all
clear in the many worlds interpretation
what do you think about this criticism
yeah I think it's not a criticism I
think it's just a statement you know as
a mini world's proponent
um
so I would agree with the claim the
algebra of observables the role the
algebra Observer role of the algebra
observables is extremely clear in other
interpretations not and it's less clear
in many worlds why because in all the
other interpretations you put the
algebra in there by hand you know you
add extra superstructure whereas many
worlds is the simplest cleanest
interpretation of quantum mechanics so
when it comes to things like observables
just like things like branching and
probabilities and so forth you have to
derive them they're emergent you don't
just put them in by hand so it's less
clear in many worlds because it's more
work and this is something where
I think any uh Fair Observer would say
this kind of feature of many worlds is
both an advantage and a disadvantage of
the theory it's an advantage because
rather than just positing something
people who believe in many worlds are
saying we can derive that thing it's a
disadvantage because maybe you can't
derive that thing maybe you think you
can and you're just fooling yourself and
it's more work to show it right so I
mean I take the the worry very very
seriously the paper I wrote just last
year with ashmeet Singh on Quantum
myriology tackles exactly this problem
of showing how the algebra of
observables arises in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics I
think we have a pretty good explanation
of why it does
um so I'm not that worried but I but you
know I want to agree with the problem
and then I want to say yeah but we can
solve it and solving it is good right
that's that's what we're here for so uh
by all means criticize away especially
those criticisms that I have answers to
that sounds good
Richard McClay says I recently listened
to a somewhat frustrating podcast on
post-modernism and post-truth what are
your thoughts on the existence of
objective truth so I don't know why your
uh podcast you listen to is frustrating
so I'm not sure what side it was
frustrating on
um look I believe in objective truth in
the following sense I believe in
objective reality
I believe that there is a world that
objectively exists out there you know
that we're part of okay and that there
are certain statements we can imagine
making about the world which would be
correct and certain ones that would be
incorrect about the physical behavior of
that world okay uh on the other hand I'm
more Pro post-modernism than most other
scientists or physicists in particular
and part of it is that you know
um
physicists are not that patient with a
whole bunch of things you know
physicists I think this is going to come
back later in the AMA also maybe but um
we talked already about uh intellectuals
and this idea being intellectual being
devoted to Truth uh it is related to but
not the same as being
broad-ranging in the kinds of Truth you
care about right so you can be very very
devoted to finding the kind of truth in
your particular field and or your your
subject of interest and just less
interested in other fields that's a
perfectly valid thing to do again no one
forces you to be uh wide-ranging in
those ways
and in fact a lot of the yeah this will
come back I should have grouped these
two questions together this will we will
come back to this later in the AMA but a
lot of the you know attitudes of
physicists towards other fields are
because they're different than physics
right they they uh
they go by different standards they use
different techniques and so forth and
post-modern modernism in particular you
know pushes physicists buttons pushes
scientists buttons in all sorts of bad
ways and also just to you know layer on
more
um uh throat clearing here there's a lot
of bad post-modernism out there it's not
hard to find people just saying very
very silly things in the name of
post-modernism but I'm not interested in
the bad post-modernism uh you know I
want to ask is there any good
post-modernism is that any useful uh and
I think that there is there's a point
there's an Insight an essential Insight
in the postmodern project which is that
even if the world exists and is
objective we don't know it clearly and
objectively and in an unmediated way
right we are tiny finite biased beings
and so even though we exist in the world
the stories that we tell about the world
whether they're literally stories or
whether they're highly developed in a
highly rigorous physics theories
um are partial attempts to capture a bit
of the world and we should be very
they're very fallibleistic right we
should be willing to change them when
new data comes in and when it comes to
physics that Insight is kind of trivial
and not very helpful right you know sure
well if new experiments come in that
tell us to change our theories we should
do that right uh but we're pretty sure
that you know apples will still fall
from trees no matter what we learn about
gravity uh a hundred years in the future
or a million years in the future
when you turn it to things that
post-modernists more typically care
about which is the social world and uh
supposed truths of
ethics or morality or Society or
politics or literature or art as we're
talking about art before then the fact
that these truths are fallible and
partial is much more important to keep
in mind because you can be fooled much
more easily when you talk about these
harder areas than when you talk about
physics physics is easy it's easy to do
experiments to find out whether you're
right or wrong it is it is
easier in other areas
to fall into a trap that you think you
got things figured out that you have a
way of talking about the world that is
just correct even though you're actually
embedded in a web of presuppositions
that should be questioned right and I
think that's the usefulness of
post-modernism that uh that
post-modernism gives you a tool kit for
questioning these presuppositions for
saying that well you know I know that
sounds like some objective truth about
the world but have you thought of this
right that's that's the good variety of
post-modernism uh post-truth I'm not
even sure what that means I think that
the phrase post-truth is almost always
used as a uh slander against people you
don't like right like I don't see anyone
really who is you know positively in
favor of poster truth I I don't see
anyone making the case the truth is
overrated and we should get rid of it
you know not any sensible people again
there's always crazy people out there
um but the idea that truth is a idea
that has outlived its usefulness is
really not one that is is gaining a lot
of currency among smart people in the
world today uh usually the accusation of
being post-truth is made against your
enemies to say that they are distorting
the truth in some way or another and
again that absolutely happens especially
when it comes to politics and activism
right when you're first
loyalty is to a political goal rather
than uh an intellectual goal then you
will often end up distorting the truth
and everything I just said applies
equally well no matter which side of the
political Spectrum you are on
um
but but
I think it's a bit lazy and useless that
particular accusation this post-truth
accusation because it misreads what
people are trying to do because I don't
think that people describe themselves as
post-truth usually so what they how they
would describe themselves which is
always what I think you should be asking
you know what is the people who really
believe this what is their
self-understanding uh they might have
different ways of finding the truth and
judging the truth than you do they might
count different pieces of evidence and
weigh them differently than you do and
that doesn't mean that they're not wrong
in a real objective sense but if they're
wrong confront them on why they're wrong
be honest about it you know what is the
evidence where are they going wrong
where are they making the mistake to
just sort of say well you're not even
aiming for the truth I think it's just a
kind of lazy criticism that is
rhetorically beneficial to your side but
again it's that activist mindset rather
than an intellectual mindset in my mind
and again all of that everything I just
said is usually but of course there's
plenty of exceptions out there
Casey Mahone says given that all
branches of the wave function are
equally real
there would be presumably some bizarre
unexplainable things happening in some
branches a car passing through a wall an
elephant appearing out of thin air Etc
given the enormous number of times the
wave function branches every second is
it possible that some of these freaky
events have occurred in the history of
our own Branch thus accounting for some
ghost stories or other bizarre phenomena
so as I said before whenever a question
starts with is it possible the answer is
usually going to be yes it's possible
but look
um you have to just ask this question a
little more carefully you have to think
it through uh yes in the branches of the
wave function and everybody in quantum
mechanics some unlikely things will
happen
um and many things happen in the world
and you want to say okay there's a a
number less than one the probability of
some unlikely event and then there's a
number of times that we look at events
okay so you have some big number the
number of times you look at events times
some small number the likelihood of each
unlikely event and you want to say
therefore when you multiply these two
numbers together is it likely that
unlikely events happened okay but you
haven't Quantified what either one of
those are here and roughly the answer is
that the unlikely events are really
really unlikely
so unlikely that even if a lot of events
happen you're not going to see that many
very very unlikely events so in quantum
mechanics there are events like I put
the coffee cup on the table and it
quantum tunnels right through
what is the likelihood of this happening
and you can say like look there's been a
lot of coffee cups put on tables
throughout human history surely it
should have happened well no
if the probability if the number of
coffee cups have been put on tables is I
don't know 10 to the 20 that's way
bigger than the actual number but okay
that's a lot of coffee cups being put on
tables but the chances that the coffee
cup tunnels through the table is 10 to
the minus a million which is a very
which actually overestimates the
probability for it happening so what
this means is that no you can't just go
qualitatively from some unlikely things
are going to happen to probably they
explain things it's way easier to
explain ghost stories by saying people
mistook what they saw late at night in
the dark that's a way easier explanation
than invoking the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
okay David Frank says if you were Daryl
Mori former mindscape guest and
president of operations for the
Philadelphia 76ers what would you do
with Ben Simmons this off season
I know not everyone here is a basketball
fan but I thought this was an
interesting enough question to address
because it you know the the reason why I
thought it was fun to have Daryl on the
podcast is because deciding what to do
as a general manager in a basketball
situation is it completely analogous to
a whole bunch of other very real world
decision problems that we make the
difference is that in basketball or in
other professional sports just like in
poker which we've also talked about the
results are very quantitative and very
quick right so you can be a little bit
more careful about saying well you know
should I make this decision or should I
make that decision in the real world
when it's like should I get married or
should I not get married it's hard to
know whether you made the right decision
or not because it's hard to see what
would have happened in the other choice
um so Ben Simmons is the point guard
All-Star basketball player Young player
still 24 years old for the Philadelphia
76ers he did not perform well in the
playoffs this year I think that is safe
to say
he is a very polarizing figure
among NBA fans because you know the
basic thing in basketball all you need
to know is you put the ball in the
basket to score points and the team that
scores the most points wins so that
sounds like there's only one thing that
happens is you put the ball in the
basket but the other thing that happens
is that you stop the other team from
putting the ball in the basket but the
it's way easier to be quantitative and
judgmental about people's ability to
score to shoot the basketball to put the
ball in the basket than it is other
things playing defense passing
rebounding and so forth and the reason
why Ben Simmons is so polarizing is
because he's clearly super duper
talented but he's he's absolutely super
world class at everything but putting
the ball in the basket
the one skill set especially for the
point guard the guy who runs the offense
the one skill set that is really really
important and very easy to see when it's
on display is shooting the ball and Ben
Simmons is not any good at that
um
and and some of it is
who knows why I mean some of it is
psychological some of it is just that he
wants to do other things and is actually
quite smart about it uh some of it
people claim that you know he shoots
with his left hand even though he's
naturally right-handed which is true but
you know can you overcome that so
there's a lot going on Simmons is very
good at passing very good at running
very good at defending he's arguably the
best defender in the NBA how do you
value
a player like that so that's a good
question yeah I really don't know you
know I think that um the the reason why
sports fans are sometimes very annoying
to read online or even to talk to is
that they ask questions like this what
would you do with Ben Simmons this off
season uh knowing perfectly well the
options are you keep them on the team
but you try to like Smooth over those
rough edges get him to shoot more get
them better at shooting Etc or you trade
him but to trade him requires another
team to offer you something in return
and in fact uh Ben Simmons is very
valued around the league people will
offer you something in return but they
know everyone else knows that he didn't
do that great in the playoffs uh that
the fans are sort of grumbling about his
playoff performance Etc so maybe the
other general managers are not going to
offer fair value you just don't know
you know I'm a as a basketball fan I'm
I'm a fan I'm not the general manager I
don't I don't have a say in what happens
um
so I tend to root for my players right
like you know it might be true look I
mean the short version is if you could
get a trade that you could get Damien
Lillard on the Sixers in favor of Ben
Simmons I would do it I would sort of do
it right away
I don't know if that's a possible thing
to do if we don't trade Ben Simmons and
keep him on the team then I would
actually be perfectly happy with that
he's a really really good player I don't
want to trade him for Worse players just
for the sake of saying that we did
something so
um we'll see what happens you know I'm
glad I'm not Daryl Mori in this
particular case but uh it'll be an
interesting off season Sixers fans
I'm going to group a couple of questions
together here
um they're all about expanding space so
one is from nuzzly fuzzly Torsten pill
of the satanic temple I think some of
you people are editing your names just
to get me to say them out loud in these
amas question is it's my understanding
that the Universe has a kind of
resolution of punk size as the universe
expands is the Planck's size ever so
slightly increasing too or is the
universe increasing the amount of to put
it in a cutesy way plonkies
William Garrett says since matter
including ourselves is mostly empty
space and the universe seems to be
expanding are we expanding with it is
subatomic space expanding similarly to
outer space and then Paul Hardy says I
read an article suggesting that
inflation Theory might mean that space
has been expanding forever I've also
heard that space might not be
fundamental are these two ideas
contradictory so there's a bunch of
ideas that are similar in these three
questions even though they're different
um one thing that I do want to emphasize
is that the res don't believe that the
Universe has a resolution of the punk
scale that is not the right way to think
about the Planck scale so the Planck
scale is a measure of length there's
also the clock time the punk energy
Planck Mass Etc that you get from
combining Newton's constant of gravity
Planck's constant of quantum mechanics
and the speed of light I think that the
correct way to interpret that is if you
have processes in physics
that in some sense are happening at the
Planck scale so in other words uh things
that are squeezed down into lengths
smaller than the Planck length or
processes that happen faster than the
Planck time or collisions that exchange
more than the Planck energy right in any
one of these cases examples
then you will have to take into account
gravity relativity and quantum mechanics
because all those constants are in that
formula for these different length
scales what does it mean to take into
account gravity relativity and quantum
mechanics nobody knows really okay it
does not mean that there's the little
pixels of Planck volume or anything like
that maybe that's true but maybe that's
not true we don't really know enough
about quantum gravity to actually say so
the question about you know
is the Planck size increasing no it's
not as far as we know it's a formula in
terms of these concepts of Nature and
those constants don't seem to be
changing over time
um
there's a different version of this
question
that is related to what Paul says you
know I've also heard that space might
not be fundamental or these two ideas
contradictory so if
space emerges from quantum entanglement
of degrees of freedom of abstract
degrees of freedom as we were talking
about earlier then there's actually a
really nice way of thinking about the
expansion of the universe namely that
there's a certain number of fundamental
degrees of freedom that come together to
form to describe any one region of space
and what happens as the universe expands
is not that more space is created which
would be this sort of traditional
classic way classical way of thinking
about it but rather more degrees of
freedom are becoming entangled
so you imagine you know there's a
collection of quantum mechanical degrees
of freedom they're all entangled with
each other and making up space or space
time and there's a separate bucket of
degrees of freedom that are not
entangled in some well-defined way
there's subtleties and there's math
there that I'm glossing over but
hopefully the image comes through
and that what you mean by the expansion
of the universe is more and more of
these unentangled degrees of freedom are
becoming entangled and space appears to
expand I actually wrote about that in a
paper that I wrote with some other you
know collaborators called Quantum
circuit cosmology
it was a very vague suggestion at the
time so we don't have any you know
tangible
things to do with that picture but it's
very attractive to me in terms of
understanding the relationship between
entanglement and expanding universes
um and then for William's question about
is uh the universe expanding are we
expanding or subatomic space expanding
no
that's easy no it's not because and I
think I said this elsewhere but the fact
that space is expanding is an
exaggeration parts of space are
expanding and in fact when you go really
deep into the math of it it's impossible
to attach
um definite ideas of where space is
expanding and where it isn't what it is
possible to say is that this particular
Galaxy is further away from us now than
it used to be it takes longer for light
to get there and to get back and
but within a gravitationally bound
system like a Galaxy or a planet or a
person there's no expansion of space
going on it's only the regions in
between the galaxies that are actually
expanding
okay then
there's a bunch of uh questions about
entropy and I think I'm going to group
them into three groups entropy questions
the first is these two questions one
from Canon close who says you've
demonstrated entropy by mixing cream and
coffee they're interesting swirls before
we meet reach Maxim entropy but I tried
the experiment and about a day later the
cream had risen to the top the mixture
had been unmixed I don't think you
should leave out your cream and coffee
for over a day but I get I know I do
know what you're talking about Ken and
then relatedly Richard Graff says my
understanding from discussions on
mindscape is that there are two
definitions of entropy one subjective
that measures an observer's knowledge of
a system and one objective that measures
the disorder of a system how are these
two definitions related so let me answer
the second one first there there's
actually many different definitions of
entropy more than just two but there are
there is a fundamental distinction and I
I wouldn't put it exactly the way that
you did but I know why you're putting it
that way
so one way of thinking about entropy is
as you say characterizing our observer's
knowledge of a system so if you have a
system that could be given your
knowledge in any one of several States
right I mean you can think about the
cream in the coffee for example you're
not knowing exactly where the individual
atoms are of water or molecules of cream
or coffee Etc so you can rearrange them
to get a system that looks the same so
you assign some probability distribution
to all the specific microscopic
Arrangements of the atoms and then from
that there's a formula that uh boltzmann
and Gibbs and others developed to
calculate the entropy okay so that is
manifestly a definition that is talking
about your knowledge there's another way
which is also subjective in a very real
sense but seems more objective
which is before you look at the cup of
coffee decide ahead of time what you are
able to see okay so there's certain
things you can observe about the system
certain things that are macroscopically
accessible to us and Chunk Up the set of
all microstates into macro States
saying that if two macros to if two
microstates are in the same macro State
then they must be observably
indistinguishable they look the same to
you okay so that once you do that once
you decide what your observables are
then you have a objective chunking of
the space of all possible States into
macro States and then what you can say
is
you can assign an entropy which is
basically the size of a macro State it's
actually the logarithm of the size of a
macro State given that you know that the
system is in a certain kind of macro
State you can assign an entropy to it no
matter what you know about it no matter
what you know about the microstate okay
so it's not that you don't even if you
know the microstate
if it's in a big macro State you can
still assign a large entropy to it so
that's kind of Quasi objective
quasi-subjective the the subjective step
was you defined macro States
the objective part is once you define
that there's an entropy that you can
associate with every microstate how are
they related in the obvious way
namely that if your
subjective knowledge of the system is
precisely that it's in a certain macro
State and nothing more so then you put a
probability distribution on all the
different microstates which is equal
probability for every possible
microstate in that macro State and zero
probability for not being in that macro
State and then the two entropy formulas
coincide they give you the same answer
so they're compatible in that sense
now Ken's asking about the cream and the
coffee and that's because this of course
very very possible you don't even need
to use cream and coffee right try to mix
oil and water do your best they quickly
unmix much less than a day it takes and
that's just because you know we're being
a little sloppy about the detailed
interactions of the different molecules
in the system okay so for cream and
coffee it's even more subtle but oil and
water work better oil molecules often
have a hydrophilic component and a
hydrophobic component so given all the
different ways given a certain energy in
the system it will often happen that
secretly the highest entropy states have
the cream and the the oil in the water
separated from each other likewise for
the cream and coffee when you're in a
gravitational field and so forth and the
molecules have different weights it can
be the case
that the highest entropy States at a
certain uh uh temperature and so forth
are would the cream and the coffee are
separate from each other because they're
different kinds of things so a better
example would be if you had you know red
balls and blue balls in a big box of gas
uh with their masses and their
interaction properties exactly the same
but just different colors then they
would really want to mix together so all
of these typical things are just
supposed to be ways of getting you to
get your brain around the idea of things
mixing together but when you use as
often true in the real world actual
substances that real physics can be more
complicated than that
okay the next group of questions about
entropy Travis Hank says PBS FaceTime
did a video explaining how the growth of
quantum entanglement drives the
inexorable increase of entropy we see in
the microscopic world my question is why
was there an initial state where the
particles were not maximally entangled
Nicholas weiberg says is there a close
relationship between Quantum coherence
and the increase of entropy both seem to
be related to The Arrow of time and both
seem to involve statistical system
descriptions
Michelle vincenzi says did the Big Bang
create the uni the Multiverse or was it
already going if it was already going
would it be right to assume that we got
different Big Bangs in each universe or
even universes with nobody bang at all
or some completely different process
and Kathy Seeger says in your
conversation on the podcast with Max
tegmark you both agreed on giving more
Credence to an everedian Multiverse than
to a cosmological Multiverse to exist
I wondered if when the Big Bang started
off the universal wave function also
kicked in right from the start wouldn't
it be likely that branching already
affected very very early states of the
evolving universe and therefore in the
process creating multiverses in the
cosmological sense
so hopefully the connection there is is
clear those are four questions sorry
about the length there the first two
were explicitly about quantum
entanglement uh and entropy the second
two were about the initial conditions of
the universe and those that's very
related to this question of entropy so
um very quickly You Know Travis uh you
say that PBS space-time did video
explaining how the growth of quantum
entanglement drives the inexorable
increase of entropy we see in the macro
world I don't think that's true actually
it you know as I said just for the
previous question there's more than one
or more than two definitions of entropy
and indeed one of the other definitions
of entropy is a strictly quantum
definition that John Van Neumann
invented a fourth definition is from
Claude Shannon in the in the process in
the context of information Theory but
Quantum entropy sometimes called Von
Neumann entropy or entanglement entropy
has to do with the entanglement between
different Quantum systems
and the formula for that entropy turns
out to be the same as the formula that
boltzmann invented in the completely
different classical context but the
point is that Quantum entropy exists and
it's important for things like
decoherence this is Nicholas's question
um
Quantum entropy of one system
increases when that system becomes
entangled with the outside world and of
course the most famous example that is
decoherence when you become entangled
with the environment your total
entanglement goes up so your total
entropy goes up so to Nicholas's
question is there a close relationship
between Quantum D coherence and the
increase of entropy yes that's it
quantum decoherence necessarily
increases the entropy of a system as
long as you don't like collapse the wave
function and reset that that can lower
the entropy but to Travis's question
um that Quantum entropy is a form of
Entry but it's a different form of
entropy than the classical entropy when
you're mixing cream into coffee and you
say entropy goes up or when you shuffle
a deck of playing cards and you say
entropy goes up that has nothing to do
with quantum entanglement right there
okay that's just a classical notion of
entropy so these are different Notions
of entropy both very important uh and
then your question about the initial
State you know why did everything start
out unentangled this is related to the
later two questions and the answer is I
don't know no one knows that is a big
big question in fact we're going to have
a podcast coming up about this soon
um but the point being that that's a
major unanswered question in cosmology
why did the early Universe have a
special state which can be described as
low entropy or maximally entangle I
would like no I have theories you know I
proposed a model with Jennifer Chen huh
16 years ago now or something like that
uh um where baby universes help
understand it but I don't know if that's
true or not uh that it's it's one of my
favorite ideas but it's a it's an open
question so to uh Michelle or bikeli
sorry I don't know uh question
um would it be right to assume that we
got different Big Bangs in each universe
and you know
um and then Kathy's question is related
to that you know is there branching that
gives you different parts of the
Multiverse so these are questions about
the fact that the early Universe had a
special initial State that's just an
empirical fact mostly an empirical
factors some subtleties there sorry
about that but it's a fact it's a true
thing the initial state of our
observable universe seems to be special
let's put it that way
um and the cosmological Multiverse is a
different conceptual idea than the
Eveready in many worlds ever any many
worlds are caused by branching of the
wave function and they're literally full
copies of the whole universe that can
happen right in this room right away
right when I measure a spin or something
like that whereas the cosmological
Multiverse is an essentially classical
concept that says that far away there
are regions of space swear conditions
look very different so different that
you might as well call it another
universe but you're right you're both
right in this implication here which is
that these two Notions can be connected
um
imagine that you have a wave function
that branches so you're creating an
ever-ready and many worlds kind of
situation but different branches
uh have different local laws of physics
now normally that's not what happens
right that is not inherent in the many
worlds interpretation at all but it
could happen if the events that are
causing branching are the kinds of
events that lead to the cosmological
Multiverse namely bouncing around from
one vacuum state in a landscape of
possible vacuum States in a more modern
Theory like string theory or extra
Dimensions or something like that so
this is an idea and you can look up I
don't remember what it was called I did
a blog post about it years ago
um this idea was actually pursued in in
two different papers that came out near
the same time one by yasinori namura and
one by Leonard Tuscan and Rafael buso
and both of them pointed out that he
could sort of combine the many worlds
idea with the cosmological Multiverse
and say that in different branches you
had effectively different parts of the
cosmological Multiverse I think that's
right that sounds right to me
um it didn't you know take the world uh
by storm because it's not clear what to
do with it exactly it's not clear
that you solved any problems by pointing
this out it seems to be a true feature
um but it doesn't help you explain why
the early Universe had low entropy or
why our universe looks the way it does
but maybe it's you know something to
keep in mind when you're thinking about
cosmology and entropy and the big bang
and the Multiverse and all that stuff
okay I have one more group the third
group of entropy questions one is from
Nick G
who says where does entropy in the
second law of Thermodynamics fit into
the fundamentalness hierarchy is it just
an emergent phenomenon that isn't
exactly written into the source code of
the universe or is it something deeper
and more fundamental
Paul torik says Nick G's question about
where entropy fits into the
fundamentalness hierarchy inspires my
question do we even need a
fundamentalness hierarchy or is it just
a matter of which order of presentation
of facts we find explanatory and or
which statements of laws and boundary
conditions are simpler or is the latter
all that is meant by fundamental so let
me talk a little bit about my view of
this fundamentalness hierarchy and then
hopefully that will illuminate both
questions
um
the idea of a fundamentalist hierarchy
is an old one
I mean at least August comp to I think
was mostly interested in sociology
talked about this over a hundred years
ago and it's also very natural we sort
of take it for granted all the time you
know you're a human being you're an
individual an organism all by yourself
you're a part of bigger structures
you're part of a society you're part of
the whole Earth and you're also made of
smaller structures you're made of organs
your organs are made of cells the cells
are made of molecules made of particles
Etc so there's kind of an obvious
hierarchy and I do think it's more or
less subjective uh in that big things
are made of little things in the
universe as we see it now I don't think
that that's necessary if we if we sit
back and think about all the different
possible
laws of physics that we could imagine
um ways the universe could be put
together is it necessary that no matter
what kind of source code we started with
um would we always end up with some kind
of fundamentalness hierarchy no I don't
think that's necessarily true it's a
feature of there's a couple of
ingredients that go into it the most
important of which is locality right
that there is something called space
that there are objects located in space
and they tend to bump into each other
when they're nearby and not when they're
far away that's the fundamental feature
of the world it didn't have to be there
there are other ways of thinking about
worlds which wouldn't have that feature
but that enables this
feature of conglomeration of small
things into bigger things but there's an
additional feature over and above that
which is that there is something
real about treating
collections of many small things as
things in and of themselves right so in
other words we take the world and we
divide it up into things and that's sort
of a not an innocent move there's you
can question why do you divide up into
this set of things so I forget exactly
the example that I've heard but the
collection of atoms in your body
come together to form you and it makes
sense to talk about you why well because
it has some causal role in the world I
can make statements like you went there
you did this if I tell you this you will
act in a certain way there's a higher
level theory of where you fit into
things right
whereas if I make some collective object
uh consisting of your left foot and this
cup of coffee and that oak tree out
there that's an object I can Define
right but it doesn't have any role in
the world there's no theory in which
that collection of things has an
autonomous existence or or useful way of
talking about it so there is something
real even though it's convenient for us
to talk about these higher level
emerging phenomena there are right and
wrong ways of doing it right there are
there are better and worse ways of
dividing the world into objects and that
goes back into Nick's question
um
the second law of Thermodynamics is not
fundamental if you were laplace's demon
or the quantum mechanical equivalent
thereof if you knew exactly the
microstate of the universe you wouldn't
have to do any of this coarse graining
or thinking about our ignorance you
wouldn't have any ignorance so you
wouldn't have any entropy uh to deal
with
but the fact that there is a useful
concept called entropy that has causal
explanatory power right we can explain
things going on in the universe by
talking about entropy increasing Etc
means that there is some reality to that
concept so it's not fundamental but it
is real right that's that's what I
that's my point of view on emergent
phenomena more generally so hopefully
that helps with those questions okay
enough about entropy there
um Allison says could krasnikov tubes
permanent superluminal tunnels in
principle be used to construct Galaxy
sized telescopes uh I don't know I guess
maybe
um I I presume I had something in mind
to say about this question when I when I
kept it in the list of things I'm uh
trying to answer but um you know this is
the kind of thing I mean maybe this is
what I wanted to say
um
the space of
speculative ideas that naturally suggest
themselves to human beings is very
different and potentially unconnected to
the space of speculative ideas that
could be true
in other words you know the way I think
of it is you know think about old
science fiction right 100 year old
science fiction they got some things
right space travel is true right we all
now have portable communication devices
but they missed other things right they
missed the fact that we don't have
faster than light travel they didn't
miss that but you know many of them just
let themselves helped themselves to
faster than like travel uh whereas no
one really invented the Internet or
something like that and and very few
um went into sort of modern synthetic
biology or things like that so the the
our ability to predict real world
scientific advances is uneven why well
one of the reasons why is because the
kinds of advances that it's easy to
predict are taking things we already do
and imagine we can do them better
we already a hundred years ago could
travel we could fly we had cars we even
had airplanes right uh we could make you
know small things that go through the
air so it's just easy to extrapolate
them to faster things and things that go
further away Etc whereas a conceptually
new category like the internet is harder
to imagine so when you say you know
permanent superluminal tunnels
they're not going to exist honestly like
in the real world that's just not going
to happen
um if you did but but they're the kinds
of things that we are tempted to imagine
because we can already go pretty fast
and it's easy to imagine going
arbitrarily fast
um I don't exactly see you might be
getting at some issue with the telescope
question I'm not quite sure why a super
luminal tunnel would help us build a
telescope but I just did want to say
that's not the way that I would spend my
money honestly if I were thinking or
even spend my time thinking about
possible future Technologies
okay Michael lesniak says I first became
familiar with you on Science Channel
shows like Through the Wormhole and I'm
curious how did the interview process
for shows like that go who contacted who
and how come I haven't seen you on any
more recent shows like that uh well for
the recent shows question I think that
um
I mean maybe this actually goes to the
first part of the question the process
is very informal about being contacted
like someone looks you up in fact yeah
let me let me back up and explain how
these shows are very often made
different shows are made in different
ways like a PBS show a Nova show will
very often be based on a book or
something like that when Brian Greene
does his elegant Universe books or
something like that then turns them into
a Nova series uh he's very involved in
what is going on but for History Channel
shows or Science Channel shows or
Discovery Channel shows the process is
different and often it's not a very good
process
Through the Wormhole was one of the
better examples but here is the basic
process
the TV network hires a production
company to make a show Through the
Wormhole or the universe or you know
Mysteries of the universe or whatever
the production company hires a director
or producer to sort of be in charge of
the particular show and that director or
producer hires writers what does that
mean you hire some people who are TV
writers they work for the production
company and their job is to come up with
an episode and maybe there is some
brainstorming among some people about
what the topic of the episode should be
let's say the black hole information
laws puzzle okay and then this writer or
you know uh production assistant or some
other sets of people the producer
themselves
goes on the internet Google's around
looks for experts especially looks for
experts nearby this is why living in Los
Angeles is very helpful if you want to
be on these TV shows
um and says you know who can I talk to
about this and so they will sketch out
you know from Wikipedia and other things
you know other videos they see on
YouTube they'll sketch out their idea of
what the good things to talk about are
and get some ideas of who they might
want to talk to and then they might call
you up and interview you and decide
whether they want to have you on camera
or not
but the point is that
none of the people involved in that are
scientists right they interview the
scientist uh once they get on camera but
the writing and the organizing and
deciding what to do on the show is
rarely Guided by people who are
knowledgeable about science and so the
individual segments are often perfectly
respectable but the overall vision of
where to go is not there because there's
no no one really scientifically informed
guiding it they don't hire a scientist
to do that kind of thing so and that
sometimes leads to
um embarrassing things like uh I was
once doing a demonstration for one of
these TV shows about dark matter and I
think I've told the story before but I
was asked to you know spin a light bulb
above my head and they were going to put
special effects in there so the light
bulb would light up Etc and this was
supposed to be dark matter and so I
asked uh am I representing the dark
matter and the things around me is
supposed to be like a star or something
that is feeling my gravitational field
and the people filmingly honestly didn't
know there have been so many steps in
between when someone came up with the
idea for this analogy and when we got to
filming it that the meaning of it had
been lost right and and that can happen
sometimes but in other times
um the shows turned out really well I
you know I'm I'm if you get the
impression I think it would be better if
a lot of these shows took the scientific
side more seriously and actually let
scientists be involved but that would
involve money and things like that so
who knows that will ever happen
um why haven't I been on any more recent
shows like that I have been on a couple
but not that many partly you know it's
just small number of statistics about
when you get invited partly there's a
pandemic partly I've been busy so
sometimes I've had to say no when I get
invited to do these things it's a weird
thing you know you reach a lot of people
but you don't have a lot of control over
what's being said as I get older and
grumpier I like to have more control
over what's being said
Paul Hess says is a nation of millions
of people conscious uh rough answer is
no I don't think so but it's an
interesting question and you can ask it
at different levels of precision you
know I think that you know if you look
into things like into uh what is it
called integrated information Theory IIT
this idea of Julio tanoni and
collaborators where they try to actually
answer this question precisely they they
propose a measure that is quantitative
uh they can sort of pinpoint the level
of emergence at which you would call
something conscious the idea of being
let's say you have a mob of people if
they're just acting randomly and
differently than each individual person
is conscious but sometimes you get mob
Behavior where in some sense it makes
more sense to attach the locus of
Consciousness to the Mob rather than to
any individual inside it I don't think
that that's very helpful in the case of
a nation of millions of people we do it
all the time we do the equivalent thing
because we attach
beliefs desires attitudes uh
psychologies to countries of people
um but it's it's often just a shorthand
for what should be a more nuanced way of
talking about things
we don't have the once and for all
definition of Consciousness so I'm not
quite sure if we can carefully answer
this question at all but I think that
roughly speaking my answers tentatively
no
okay Jeff B asks a priority question
remember the priority questions are once
in your life you get to answer a
priority question I promise to answer it
to the best of my ability uh sometimes
my ability is not very good so be
careful about how you ask your priority
question so Jeff's question is the
question boils down to how a waving
field ends up getting detected as a DOT
on a detector screen your previous
answer was basically local interactions
plus decoherence this makes sense to me
but only under the assumption that the
dots are somehow given special treatment
during wave function branching otherwise
I could imagine the wave function
branching so that each branch saw
something other than a DOT appear on the
screen a circle triangle whatever my
understanding is that these dots are
special because they are pointer states
that are stable under decoherence so my
question becomes a bit meta why are
these pointer States why are these at
the pointer States and not something
else
our world would probably look very
different if the wave function branched
differently but it seems that there has
got to be some underlying ontological
reason for why it branches in this
particular way
so I think the answer is I mean it is
because of locality uh plus d coherence
but you're right that there's more steps
to that story a little bit you know
um you have a gun shooting electrons or
something like that at a screen in
principle the wave function is spread
out over different points but in fact uh
when you see the screen light up it's at
one point it's not at either the whole
smeared wave function nor is that some
weird shaped subsystem like a circle or
triangle or whatever why is that
basically the reason is that what
pointer states are
our parts of the wave function which
have the property that once they're
there once you're in them they don't
keep getting extra entanglement with the
rest of the world remember entanglement
is a special kind of quantum mechanical
interaction like if you if you take a
basketball and bounce it on the floor
the basketball does not become entangled
with the floor because the whole
basketball interacts with the floor in
exactly the same way
if you had a basketball that was in a
superposition of let's say spinning and
not spinning okay and then you bounced
that on the floor then the spinning part
of the basketball wave function would
bounce in One Direction and the
non-spinning part would bounce in
another Direction
so those two parts of the wave function
would separate they would decohere
because they would become entangled with
the rest of the world that would be an
interaction that entangles them so the
point about the electron or whatever
hitting a detector screen is that think
about the ways that that part of the
wave function interact with the rest of
the world
the electron interacts with the detector
screen and then it leaves a DOT or
leaves an impression that you can see by
looking at it right there's some change
in the color or the brightness or
whatever of the screen so you can
imagine tracing out a circular pattern
on the screen but in fact all of those
parts of the circle interact differently
with the world they all give out what is
amounts to a photon but photons moving
in different directions because they're
coming from different angles on the
screen
all of the parts of the wave function
where the electron hits in the same
point
interact in the same way with the rest
of the world that's why it is a pointer
State a much more Vivid example is
something like schroederer's cat right
where it's alive plus dead or awake plus
asleep if you want to buy T-shirts from
the merch store and mindscape you can
get an awake plus and a sleep cat on
your T-shirt
the awaken asleep part of the cat's wave
functions interact differently with the
rest of the world because they're in
different macroscopic positions so it's
that position that comes in in all the
cases whether it's the basketball or the
cat or the electron hitting part of the
screen different positions where the
interaction happens lead to different
kinds of entanglement with the rest of
the world and that's why pointer States
tend to be the subsets of the wave
function that are sort of
macroscopically coherent that describes
something definite in space and in the
case of an electron hitting a screen
that's going to be hitting at a point in
space hitting at a point on the screen
Claudio slamovitz says I read a
biography of Fred Hoyle and he strikes
me as a fascinating figure he seems to
have made important contributions
especially on nucleosynthesis he also
had controversial later debunked views
such as the steady state universe how is
Hoyle perceived in the physics World an
underrated genius or a crackpot uh I
think he's perceived as a rated genius
you know his his insistence for the
steady state universe uh was quirky and
you know lost him some favor but look
there were other people who hung onto
that steady state universe long after
Hoyle went away and they definitely
should have known better
um if you're if you're sort of the
originator of an idea then I think a lot
of people will cut you some slack for
hanging on to that idea a little bit
longer
um but they would prefer it if you
changed your mind that would be better
but I do think that everyone agrees that
Fred Hoyle did a lot of great things in
theoretical physics and astrophysics
especially nucleosynthesis the origin of
the elements you know it's um there is a
book that just came out by Paul Halpern
uh contrasting Fred Hoyle and George
gamov so George gamov in some sense was
the champion of the Big Bang version of
the story and Hoyle was the champion of
the steady state version they all had
collaborators and the collaborators are
important so I don't want to brush them
apart but these are the two big
personalities uh in this game and you
know
they were both part right and part wrong
you know ultimately on the Big Bang
story Gamo was right but then you want
to explain where the elements come from
The Big Bang didn't help that much with
that it gets you helium but it's not
enough and then stars and supernovae are
necessary to get the heavier elements
and some people you know rightfully
hesitated to say well the real story
involves a little bit of this and a
little bit of that if you remember the
podcast would be with Simon dadeo
talking about why certain kinds of
explanations are favored over others the
ability of one thing to explain many
things is rightfully thought of as a
good feature for an explanation to have
and this makes people a little bit leery
uh wary I should say a little bit wary
when the right explanation seems to
involve disconnected unrelated things
but that's really very often true in the
real world that you need to invoke
disconnected unrelated things to explain
everything you see in the world and for
the formation of elements in the
universe that is very very much the case
so but people appreciate I think these
days the contributions of Fred Hoyle as
well as Gamo and others
Peter solvest says after rereading the
big picture I was wondering about strong
emergence and Quantum field theory is it
theoretically possible or mathematically
consistent to construct a Quantum field
which only interacts with other fields
if they are sufficiently complex so I'm
glad you're asking that because I'm
literally writing a paper about it right
now you know to be honest not going to
much details but I'm finishing up a
paper it'll appear soon on Consciousness
and the laws of physics and it's always
dangerous when physicists are talking
about Consciousness I get that but I'm
not saying that much actually about
Consciousness what I'm all I'm saying is
something I've said before but I'm
saying a little bit more detail namely
whatever is going on in consciousness
don't try to explain it by changing the
laws of physics that's not the way to
look the laws of physics are pretty well
established and we know a lot about them
don't add things to it to change the
laws of physics just because you want to
understand Consciousness there's other
strategies that are much more promising
and in particular there's this question
of you know locality and strong
emergence and
basically let's say it this way you know
we know that even if you think there are
other things in the universe
there are atoms in your head okay there
are electrons and protons and neutrons
in your brain and what happens to those
particles in your brain is certainly
somehow related to Consciousness okay
maybe it's the whole thing maybe it's
only a part of it maybe it's
epiphenomenal but it's somehow related
and so
one attitude is sure you have a theory
the core Theory which tells me if I have
an electron surrounded by certain other
fields how it behaves but
maybe that works at CERN or maybe it
works you know at your laboratory table
but who's to say that's the correct set
of rules for describing what an electron
does if it's in a human brain
if it's embedded in that very complex
system well the answer is
everything we know about the rules of
effective Quantum field Theory says the
electron could not possibly care less
whether it's embedded in a human brain
electrons interact locally the only
thing that affects what an electron does
is the values and the derivatives of
other fields at the same exact location
as the electron you know and in fact the
other atoms you know the human brain
seems like very complicated and dense
but the particles in the human brain are
kind of far apart from each other by
particle physics standards so we would
expect and it's just an expectation it's
not it's not a law of nature but our
expectation is that the behavior of
those electrons is perfectly local
so if you want to come up with a model
where somehow the Dynamics of individual
electrons change because it is in a
complex system like a human brain you're
welcome to try I've tried not because I
think it's true but because you know
it's sort of try to shoot it down and I
was not able to either come up with a
model where it worked or to come up with
a proof that you couldn't come up with a
model where it worked I can say with
confidence there's zero expectation of
anything like that happening except for
your desire to make the human brain be
somehow special so I wouldn't worry
about it too much but I can't tell you
that it's absolutely impossible
Andrew J says laplace's demon has
perfect knowledge of all microstates for
a single instead of time as well as the
full understanding of the true laws of
physics and can therefore predict the
future and retrodict the past
is the demon then limited to predictions
computations only for microstates if
that's the state if that's the case then
isn't the demon essentially clueless
about predicting any future that might
be meaningful to people
um I mean this is a slightly
deflationary answer but uh I don't know
what laplace's demon can do or cannot
right the demon knows all the he knows
the exact microstate of the universe and
the laws of physics and has the
computational power to both predict and
retrodink is that all the demon knows I
don't know I don't see what limits the
demon you know presumably if the demon
has that much computational power which
is a lot maybe they're also able to
figure out what the emergent properties
are you know there's no obstacle to that
in principle so you know I I the demon
was made up it was a thought experiment
you could make up a version of the demon
that's able to do that or a version that
isn't maybe the substantive part of the
question is
um could you imagine knowing the whole
micro State could you imagine imagine in
principle knowing the whole micro State
and not knowing the sort of ways to
chunk it up into emergent higher level
things if that's the question then the
answer is yes absolutely it's like if
someone gives you
well if someone takes I don't know Mac
OS right an operating system or Linux or
something like that and uh translate it
translates it into binary the assembly
code into binary and then prints it out
as a set of ones and zeros and hands it
to you without telling you what it is
could you figure out what it is I'm
predicting the answer is no even though
all the information is there you don't
have the ability to know oh yes that's
Mac OS you know 2018 version or
something like that there's a whole
nother layer of conceptual Insight that
it takes to do that so if that's what
you mean then we can at least imagine a
microstate version of laplace's demon
without implying a macro State version
Oren Harris says in your last AMA you
invoked David Lewis's possible worlds to
explain your position on the principle
of sufficient reason saying that the
fact that we live in one world rather
than the other has got to come down to a
brute fact I found your response
surprising because Lewis's modal realism
provides a reason for a parent facts and
that reason self-locating uncertainty is
the very same invoked by yourself and
answers to why do we find ourselves in
this Branch rather than the other in
everetting quantum mechanics the
anthropics that provide the reason for
apparent brute facts in the MWI are the
very same mechanism by which brute facts
can be explained in Lewis's model which
is an example of a metaphysics that at
bottom satisfies the principle's fission
Reason by being maximally symmetric not
reifying one brute fact over any other
can you expand on why you don't accept
root fact explanations of Chansey
outcomes in quantum mechanics but do it
accept them in a seemingly similar
situation so there's a lot going on here
and I kind of I'd like the question more
than I think I have a great answer to
give I want other people to think about
the question if it makes sense you know
the uh I am very fond of self-locating
uncertainty and and also uh of David
Lewis's idea I think it's his idea I'm
not even sure it's his idea that well
his way you know he is the one he's the
person from which I got the idea of
thinking about uncertainty about the
laws of physics and as self-locating
uncertainty in the space of all possible
worlds right it's just a way of thinking
about the fact that we don't know what
the laws of physics are we can imagine
different worlds with different laws and
then saying that we don't know what the
laws are is the same as saying we don't
know which of those possible worlds we
live in but
there is an important difference so I
think that you know if I get into the
nitty-gritty of your question I I don't
understand the claim that Lewis's model
satisfies the principle of sufficient
reason I think it depends on what you
mean by a reason what can I say even in
the quantum mechanics case where I think
I do understand things there is a
version of me that sees the electrons
spin up a version of me that sees the
electrons spin down
the one that's of me that sees the
electrons spin up do I get to say there
is a reason why I see it spin up and the
reason is well because there's another
one that sees it spin down and there's
symmetric I don't know if that really
qualifies as a reason you know maybe it
does and maybe that's an unambiguous
question to which there's no perfectly
good answer uh so maybe that's part of
the set of assumptions we would have to
dig into here to give you a satisfying
answer but the other thing is that I'm
not a modal realist uh I am a never
ready and I do believe in the different
branches of the wave function but I
don't believe in the reality of all the
possible worlds I'm happy to believe to
use the set of all possible worlds as a
way of thinking through our uncertainty
about the laws of physics and about
questions of causality and things like
that but I don't therefore attach to
them reality okay so to me uh it seems
most likely there is a universe even if
it's a big everadian Multiverse still
one Universe in some sense with laws of
physics and the question about why those
are the laws of physics rather than
others does not come down to
self-locating uncertainty in a set of
real actually existing worlds it's a
different kind of thing so I don't have
uh the similarity the the analogy there
the parallelism between modal realism
and everetting Quantum Mechanics for
those of you who are interested Aleister
Wilson who is a philosopher has tried to
develop that parallelism he tries to
claim that we can think of everettian
branches of the wave function as
lewisian possible worlds I don't really
get on that train but it's an
interesting way to think about the
question
says the universe is amoral and the
prospect of a no consequence after death
could either be liberating or
disappointing liberating as in this is
the one life we get to live so live it
as you please satisfy your brains whims
and fancies disappointing as in no
matter what Legacy or goodness I leave
after my death it is not going to be of
any use to be to me I'll be non-existent
do you have a different take on this
matter
um so I think neither one of those is
exactly how I would put it you know
the fact that life stops at death and
there is no afterlife is going to be
disappointing to those who place the
value that they have in their lives on
something that happens or continues on
after they're dead right
um you're not here anymore so as far as
you're concerned there's no enjoyment or
disappointment to be gained in what
happens after you die so having a legacy
and things like that
um there is a well I was going to say
it's irrelevant but there's a crucially
important exception to that which is
that you might very well now
care a lot about the prospect of doing
something that even lasts after your
death and that's perfectly valid right
so to take pleasure in establishing
something now that will only pay off
after you're dead there's nothing wrong
with that even though you won't be
around to appreciate it you're
appreciating it now that's a perfectly
100 okay but if you really thought that
somehow you needed your life after death
to care about what happened after you
died then I got some bad news for you
that's not going to happen now on the
other side
um you say this is the one life we get
to live so live it as you please and
satisfy your brain's whims and fancies
that's just an unsequitur in my mind
there's only one life we get to live
therefore live it as you please it just
does not logically follow you need some
extra premises that you've smuggled in
there I think you only get one life to
live and therefore what you experience
in this life and the impact you have on
other people's lives are the things that
matter right the things that matter are
not the experiences you will have after
death because there are no such
experiences but the experiences you have
here on Earth matter they go far beyond
your brain's whims and fancies I mean
that's a sort of an intentionally uh
belittling way to put it you know
everything good that you do in the world
and experience in the world are things
that are happening here in the world
right now and so that's okay right I
mean my attitude is just that is what
matters the stuff that you see the stuff
that you experience this is a perfectly
legitimate
basis for caring and mattering in the
world and it is in fact what actually
exists which is good
Sam Hartzog says if memory serves I was
introduced to Robert forward's Dragon's
egg novel by your recommendation on some
form or another if so thanks I love this
book
uh probably that's true I've definitely
recommended that it's not one of the
world's most famous science fiction
books but I like it so I do sometimes
recommend it the question is have modern
field theories ruled out the complex
Ultra fast nucleonic interactions that
give rise to the neutron stars chemistry
so in the book there are living beings
that live on the surface of the neutron
star that live in a sort of organic life
that is not based on
chemistry but more Nuclear Physics
um
so I don't know is the short answer to
this question I haven't read the book in
a long time and I haven't thought about
life on a neutron star in any careful
way my my simple guess would be it is
completely incompatible with what we
know about nuclear physics and the basic
reason is
there's not a lot that can happen in
nuclear physics you know the reason why
chemistry is interesting is that you can
make atoms but you can hook atoms
together in arbitrarily complicated ways
right the center piece of life is DNA
and the great thing about DNA is it's an
a periodic Crystal as Irwin Schrodinger
predicted even before was discovered
which means it can be as long as you
want without ever repeating itself right
information can be contained and uh
passed down from generation to
generation in the form of this
quasi-stable molecule and there's no
limit on how complicated in principle it
could be whereas if you're just making
things out of neutrons or even neutrons
and protons good luck with that there's
not arbitrary complexity that you can
get there as far as anyone knows as far
as I know as far as anyone that I know
knows so my guess is that's just not
possible possible that's just not how
nuclei work but I haven't thought about
it very carefully
Jim Murphy says you've said before that
you're convinced space is not
fundamental but less convinced about
time how can this be the case if space
and time were just two aspects of the
same thing
um well maybe they're not that that's
how uh but so the reason why that's a
short not very clever answer but the
reason why I wanted to talk about this
question is
it raises an interesting issue for
people who want to develop theories
beyond the currently existing theories
and this is part of what we talked about
with least Mullen in the podcast you
know there are things we know things we
don't how do we choose what kinds of
directions to move in so something that
is a major Triumph of 20th century
physics is
space and time are just two aspects of
the same thing space time
and what I'm proposing uh not just me
but what is being proposed is that
we can think about emergent space time
in a way that treats space and time
differently just like Newton would have
treated them differently so in some very
real sense it's a step backwards and you
can ask is that you know a strike
against this approach and I think the
answer is yes I think that if there were
no other strikes uh that argument you
know you're losing some progress that
had been made by physics is a perfectly
good reason to be skeptical of this
approach so if this approach is right
not that's not just my approach to
immersion space time but if the specific
version of it in which time is
fundamental but space is not
if that's true then time and space are
fundamentally different in some way and
the fact that they seem to be two
aspects of the same thing it's kind of
an accident that emerges in the big
macroscopic low energy universe is that
kind of a robust natural thing to happen
or is it a special weird thing that I
don't know okay but it it is part of the
challenge of this approach that you
would have to explain why it emerges in
that way
Alex Borland says I have a question
about the simulation hypothesis
imagine that Humanity managed to
simulate a universe complex enough to
contain intelligent life if that
intelligent life started to study their
universe and try to discover its physics
at what point would you give them credit
and say they had cracked its fundamental
laws would it be once they had figured
out all the equations our supercomputer
was running or would they have to
discover a deeper level of reality such
that the programming language they were
written in or the hardware they were
running on Etc and actually now that I
think about it I'm going to group this
question together with another one from
crather Luca who says last month in your
AMA you mentioned that eventually our
knowledge will bottom out I interpreted
this as saying that you eventually that
eventually progress stops because we
reach some cold hard facts I agree there
probably is a place where things bottom
out namely reality however how can we
ever hope to know that we've reached
such a place so Alex's question is if
you're in a simulation how do you know
that you've reached the bottom level
crafter Lucas question is how do we know
if we've ever reached the bottom level
uh yeah we don't we'll never know that
that kind of question
um you know I think that this is a no
one ever Promised You a Rose Garden when
it comes to science so I do think that
given that I'm not a modal realist given
that I think that not all possible
universes really exist there are some
fundamental features of our world and by
the way when I say that all these things
are very
tentative like I'm not absolutely wedded
to these things I'm willing to change my
mind about them but I'm just saying
where I am right now
um
there are some facts about the universe
that are explained by nothing deeper
than that's how that's the way it is
brute fact okay cold hard fact
um but we don't know which features are
like that and which are not you know the
mass of the electron actually the mass
of the electron is is dimension
dependent so the ratio of masses of the
muon and the electron that's a
dimensionless number okay is that an
accident or is there some deep
explanation for it for example why are
the fundamental laws of physics quantum
mechanical is there a deep reason for
that or is it just a thing that we just
have to accept I don't know so and I
don't think that there's anything wrong
with not knowing or even knowing whether
you will ever know so the attitude that
I would Advocate taking is it's
perfectly okay to try to answer those
questions to try to say okay why quantum
mechanics why relativity why the mass of
the electron things like that why does
the universe exist at all what's not
okay is to insist that there must be an
answer that would make you happy in
terms of some other features of the
Universe right rather than saying one of
the possible options is that's just the
way it is so I would I would Advocate
keeping the cold hard fact option as an
option well not necessarily ruling out
the search for other possible answers at
the same time and that you know there's
no point at which you say okay now I
know for sure but that's just science
you know that's just how science works
there's never a point you reach in which
you can say I'm completely sure
all right now grouping together a few
more questions because these are all
in a very different Now for Something
Completely Different questions about the
podcast so Jesse rimler says I'm
continually impressed by the variety and
quality of your guests could you tell us
a little bit about your methods of
Discovery as an author do you receive
Advanced copies of books
Russell wolf says in a recent AMA you
talked about how you always take
recommendations for podcast guests but
don't like to make any promise about
whether they will appear I was wondering
if you could say anything in aggregate
about how often a listener
recommendation results in a guest that
you otherwise weren't considering
and finally Seth says would you ever
consider a podcast where you go into
detail about your day-to-day process for
producing a podcast I really love how
accessible you've seen and how you don't
make it seem like what you do is Magic
yeah what I what I do is certainly not
magic and in fact Seth uh I don't think
it's that worthy to go into the podcast
to talk about my day-to-day process
because it wouldn't take that long I
will tell you what my day-to-day process
is and in in as much detail as anyone
would ever want to hear you know I do
have to find guests so this goes to the
questions asked by uh Jesse and Russell
um the way I find guests is a wide
variety of different things you know
sometimes people
patreons or people on Twitter or
comments on preposterousuniverse.com
podcast uh or on the Reddit there's a
subreddit Sean M Carroll subreddit uh
they make suggestions and I take them
all seriously like if I don't never
heard of the person I'll Google them or
whatever
um I get a lot of suggestions so if your
suggestion is not followed up on don't
feel bad I can't possibly do everyone
um sometimes I get a suggestion I do ask
invite that person and they say no right
and so I don't I don't ever want to this
is the biggest single reason why I don't
want to say who I'm considering because
I totally respect people's decisions not
to appear on the podcast I don't want to
sort of shame them publicly for not
appearing on my podcast that's that's
not going to happen they have every
right and anyone ever I ever invite you
to be on the podcast feel free to say no
I get it I say no all the time when I'm
invited to be on other people's podcasts
especially since I have my own podcast
now there's only so many so so large a
fraction of my time that I'm willing to
spend talking on podcasts and 98 of it
is talking on my podcast these days
um but there are other places where the
guest suggestions come from
um
uh yeah I mean you're asking about do I
get books so many books uh both because
I'm an author and I have the podcast and
I have the blog and my wife Jennifer is
a science writer we get a lot of free
books and this makes me feel very bad to
say it because when I was in college or
grad school you know I would just spend
hours in the bookstores lovingly looking
over all these books that I will never
own and now books just appear at my
house and I have to actually give many
of them away without ever reading them
because there's too many and I didn't
ask for them right they just appear and
so that's a terrible position to be in
but you know so be it
um so very often uh so I don't know why
people send me unsolicited copies of
books you can just email me and say
would you like a copy of the book that
that's a much more cost effective
measure many times if a book is coming
out now that I have a podcast
um the pr person either for the
individual author or for the publishing
house will email and say would you like
to consider this person for the podcast
or the author themselves will email me
saying would you like to could I appear
on your podcast
um and I love it both cases whether they
themselves or someone in their orbit
suggest someone for a podcast I like
being suggested people for the podcast
as long as they do not mind if I say no
again I get way more suggestions than I
can possibly take up so people who want
to argue with me when I say sorry it's
not fitting into my schedule right now
and they say no but did you consider
this that gets annoying but that usually
that very rarely happens actually most
people get it that there's a there's a
limit on how much you can possibly do
and in fact you know this is not too
surprising in the case of a long the
long existing podcast uh We've we're
actually now that I realize it we're
almost at exactly at the three year mark
for mindscape so we've existed for three
years yeah yes birthday
um
I have invited people to be on the
podcast and they've said no and then a
year later their publicity person says
would you have my author on your podcast
and usually I will say yes but you know
I get it you know life circumstances
change sometimes people say well you
know I ordinarily would like to but
right now it's not a good time all that
is fine you know I totally get it
um and other times I just want to have a
topic you know I there's some a person
or a topic that I'm interested in so no
one suggested them and I go out and find
them and you know have them on the
podcast so all of these work as I've
said before you know I want people who
have something interesting to say
something that is worth listening to I'm
not in the debunking business I don't
want to debate or argue with people even
if I disagree with them
I want to hear what they have to say and
learn from it
um and the audience also but within that
very very broad category I want
diversity I want all sorts of different
people I want people in different topic
areas I don't even want to have two of
the same field in a row if I can avoid
it right sometimes you can't avoid it
and sometimes it works out okay but I
want a diversity of fields A diversity
of perspectives I want some old people
some young people some famous people
some not so famous people the other
thing is you know you do want people who
can be good on a podcast and that's a
whole other skill set you know like I
said in another context you can be
really good at the intellectual side of
things and not the public side of things
so I want people who can articulate what
they're doing and so usually it's easy
to it's possible anyway to suss out that
Criterion but not always you know and so
I I think I you know look overall I've
been very very happy with the total set
of people that I've had on the podcast I
look back at the list of people we've
had and you know some have been more
successful than others but I'm like wow
look at all these people who appear on
this podcast that's pretty good so happy
with that
um okay then to continue on with Seth's
question about the producing the podcast
uh we set up a time I do try to make
sure that they have a microphone right
and
annoyingly uh there's this thing where
the
programs I used to actually do the
recording which is usually zencaster but
there's some other programs this is like
a website that I send the guest to and I
also go on then we can talk and record
um they keep fiddling with it and like
removing browsers that work so it used
to be that zencaster worked on all
browsers now it's only on Chrome which
is very annoying anyway once we can all
set that up set a date send them the Zen
Caster link we both appear uh and we
talk and I record it and then you know I
record it into audacity which is so I
while I record it that's not exactly
true I download the audio files from
zencaster and then I up I I import them
into audacity and edit them so audacity
is a free audio editing program
um and I don't do much editing like I
try to clean up you know I know that not
all the audio is equally good and
usually that's just because the person
on the other end is in a very echoey
room or you know very noisy microphone
or something like that and it's it's you
try to clean it up but you can't really
it's very very difficult
um but I do a little bit of that and
then you know I remove the coughs and
whatever to the extent that I can and
then I record an intro and I upload it
and it goes on the internet and the
whole thing you know it doesn't take
that long to be honest you know it's not
NPR as I tell my guests I don't put a
lot of incidental music in there I don't
do a lot of editing of like cutting and
pasting to put the con conversation in a
better order or anything like that what
we say is 99 of what you hear roughly
speaking
um so because you know as I know as I've
said it's not it's not uh what I want to
mostly do uh from an hour an hour basis
the uh other than sorry I guess the
other thing the other major aspect here
is that for some guests I really have to
catch up a little bit on what they're
doing right I have to read their stuff
or you know listen and give a talk or
something like that do research and
that's a different amount you know
obviously if I'm doing John presco
talking about Quantum Computing I know
enough I don't need to uh do a lot of
research ahead of time but for other
people you know I need to do uh some
that is that does take time but that's
part of the reason why I'm doing the
podcast that was part of my
self-motivation to nudge me into reading
some of these books and learning some of
these ideas that I wanted to for a long
time so other than that research aspect
the whole recording organizing editing
publishing takes a day roughly speaking
so one day a week uh not including the
AMA which is a whole other thing but one
day a week I can get the podcast out
which is about the maximum to be honest
I would want to devote to this unless I
became like a full-time podcaster but um
uh given that that there's other things
I want to do writing books and doing
science right
um uh one day a week is is a pretty big
commitment actually but it's not
overwhelming and that's why I'm usually
doing these amas on weekends and so
forth
um so I think that that is almost
everything there is to say about how the
podcast gets done
Gregory Mendel says a priority question
consider that you measure an electron
spin along an axis a in St Louis
spin up you go to Los Angeles spin down
you go to New York your spouse
subsequently measures the spin of the
same electron along axis B
and goes to Minneapolis it's the spin up
and to New Orleans if the spin is down
so if a equals B I think you and your
spouse are in this state which is a
superposition of
I went to LA my spouse went to
Minneapolis plus I went to New York my
spouse went to New Orleans because
they're measuring the same spin as I am
along the same axis right so they're
always going to get the same answer it's
just a single electron not two entangled
electrons
now the question continues your best
friend calls you and observes your
location
your spouse's best friend calls and
observes your spouse's location the
friends correlate their results and they
repeat for axes combinations yours and
your spouses of a b a c and b c so these
are different axes along which we could
measure the spins
question is Belle's inequality and then
he writes up Bell's inequality violated
as per quantum mechanics proving that
you and your spouse were in two places
at the same time or not uh so Gregory I
feel bad because I know there's a
priority question but I don't understand
what it is you're asking in the original
formulation you said that a was equal to
B but then later in the question you
seem to be leaving them as independent
variables where we have a b and c b
different axes so let me say things that
I think are true and hopefully they will
provide an answer to your question even
if it's not exactly matching on to the
setup that you gave to the question
um
if you do this kind of experiment so I
mean I presume you're saying
that uh that you're asking this question
in the context of many worlds you know
uh otherwise if it's not if it's just a
Copenhagen question then quantum
mechanics is quantum mechanics and
you're going to get the predictions of
quantum mechanics coming out true now
the short answer is in many worlds
quantum mechanics is still quantum
mechanics and you're going to get the
predictions of quantum mechanics namely
you will violate Bell's inequality yes
but just to be clear about what happens
if my spouse and I measure electrons
along different axes
um then in general there will be four
branches to the wave function so in the
in your original setup there's just two
branches one in which I go to La and she
goes to Minneapolis the other one of
which I go to New York and she goes to
New Orleans
if they're not the same axis there's
going to be four branches me La and her
either Minneapolis or New Orleans me New
York and her likewise right so the total
and you have to do this many times to
actually measure a probability right to
even Define what you mean by the
measured outcome of the probability in
axis a axis B Etc but given that
understanding of what actually happens
in many worlds all the ordinary
predictions of quantum mechanics are
completely true
including the violation of Bell's
inequality and there's never true that
we were in two places at the same time
uh we were in two different places on
different branches of the wave function
okay but that's just the the
wonderfulness of many worlds you can get
all the quantum mechanical predictions
um out of this situation perfectly well
so maybe I'm missing something subtle
that you're asking that question but I
hope that set of true things I just said
about many worlds helps uh helps answer
it
pu spelled piu says priority question if
you could ask an all-knowing entity any
three questions about the universe we
live in what would they be
again I'm going to apologize it was the
priority question but I don't have a
great answer
um I want to know what the laws of
physics are okay can I answer see that's
the problem with these all-knowing
entity questions like are they a
generous charitable entity who would
interpret my question in a useful way if
so I would ask what the actual laws of
physics are right and hopefully that
would include a knowledge of the
ontology of the universe what the
universe is in addition to how it
behaves right the actual laws of physics
um then I might ask a cosmodial question
about you know
um well actually my second question
would be are there objective moral
truths because I'm pretty sure the
answer is no but if the answer is yes
which would surprise me but I'm
open-minded then my third question would
be well and what are those
but if not I would probably default to a
third question of something like what
happened at the Big Bang or what
happened what is the history of the
universe like I mean how long can the
answer be right like tell me everything
that happened in the history of the
universe would be a question you'd be
tempted to answer but uh to ask but then
they might go on for too long so you
might would want some
algorithmically compressed version of
that question to be asked
Greg Fife says at this time what is your
Bayesian assessment of the possibility
that the fermilab G minus 2 result
actually demonstrates new physics if it
does turn out to be new physics do you
have any view on what that will most
likely turn out to be so remember we
talked about the G minus 2 result in my
solo podcast from a few weeks ago uh the
muon Magnetic Moment experiment at
fermilab
um you know I think that right now I'm
in a place that says it is less likely
to be new physics than not
and that has nothing to do with the
actual experiment or the experimenters
and more to do with
we've been down this road before right
there's been a lot of claimed anomalies
in the standard model of particle
physics none of them have really panned
out
um remember if I'm if I'm remembering
correctly and hopefully you also do
um the situation with the fermilab
result is that the experiment is pretty
clean like they really have measured the
Magnetic Moment of the electron of the
muon rather the difficult thing is the
theoretical prediction because in that
calculation there are contributions from
strongly interacting particles right
quarks and gluons and those are hard to
get right and it turns out there are two
different theoretical predictions for
those contributions
one of them
the one that is the one that was used in
the analysis gives you that discrepancy
that they claim between Theory and
experiment but there's another
calculation done with lattice qcd which
actually kind of agrees with the
experimental result
so if you're looking for a way that the
result might actually not be new physics
it's pretty obvious what it would be
that the theory prediction is just a
little bit off
um for for what it might could be if it
is a new physics I don't know I don't
have a favorite example of what it might
turn out to be I think there will be an
embarrassment of riches so I don't even
have a a strong candidate for what the
most likely thing is to be
the next two questions I'm grouping
together and they're kind of related to
that one
because they're about virtual particles
and Quantum Fields so Cooper says
Quantum magazine ran article about the
results of a recent muon G minus 2
experiment
which included this quote the particle
you thought was a bear muon is actually
a muon plus a cloud of other things that
appear spontaneously I've always
imagined the quantum foam is something
that exists everywhere regardless of the
local presence of any real particles
this quote however makes it sound like
virtual particles only exist in clouds
around real particles is the quantum
foam something that particles travel
through or is it something is created by
the local presence of a particle so it's
both is the short answer
um the longer but more accurate answer
is that the whole picture
of the quantum vacuum as consisting of
these particles popping in and out of
existence is deeply misleading uh still
a remnant of our insistence on thinking
of the world as something visualizable
and classical rather than Quantum states
of fields which it really is but to get
to the essence of your question in
Quantum field Theory oh I'm sorry I
forgot to ask the other question the the
next question by Peter Whaley is it's my
understanding the particles like photons
are perturbations in the electromagnetic
field my question is what makes the
disturbance in the field if it's
particles what came first the chicken or
the field okay so uh that I'm going to
answer that implicitly while I'm
answering Cooper's question the world is
made of fields
in the quantum field Theory limit anyway
gravity is probably a different story
but uh what we're talking about here in
particle physics there are fields that
you quantize and there's a Quantum State
called the vacuum which is the lowest
energy state of your Quantum field
Theory and particles are excitations
into higher energy states of that of the
fields in that Quantum field Theory and
when you ask what what is the Quantum
vacuum I mean there's a simple dumb but
correct answer which is it's the lowest
energy state of your Quantum field
Theory but in fact there's another way
of thinking about the vacuum state which
makes it much more complicated and
interesting which is to think about it
in terms of what the fields are doing so
what that really means is if I probed
the field if I poked at it and said what
happens or if I measured the value of
the different fields at different points
in space and time with different
resolutions Etc
there's a very complicated structure to
what's going on even in the vacuum even
in what you and I call empty space
and you can think about you're not
forced to but you can think about that
structure as arising from virtual
particles popping in and out of
existence okay again all that is just in
empty space but now let's go to a
non-vacuum state to stay with a little
bit of an excitation a particle
traveling through the vacuum there are
already all of these
virtual particles in the vacuum in this
picture but now there's also a real
particle and the real particle interacts
with the virtual particles so you can
think about it either way you can think
about it as the real particle is
traveling through a pre-existing cloud
of virtual particles and interacting
with them and being affected by them or
the real particle traveling is just
spitting out and then reabsorbing
virtual particles and then being
affected by those those are two
perfectly good ways of thinking about it
either way right so you will often hear
physicists who know the math underlying
this they'll talk about it either way
depending on
what is most convenient for the purposes
they're talking about at the time and
you know this is something you should
always keep in the back of your mind
physicists who do Quantum field Theory
Etc blah blah blah are constantly
translating math into words and the
language is never perfect the
translation is never exact so
um much of the time not all the time but
much of the time when you hear two
things that sound a little bit
incompatible it's just that the words
that are being used for the translation
are slightly different in the two
different cases
okay uh a person who has named
themselves anti-deshitter space is
asking a priority question in your
podcast with Max tegmark he proposes the
mathematical Multiverse in which our
universe is just one of many
mathematical structures all of which are
equally real
as a non-physicist I often wonder how
ideas like this arise when a physicist
proposes an idea like this does it
originate from some physical intuition
and attempt to be original or something
else what Credence should we or can we
assign to theories that are not testable
you know I think the the general
question of where new hypotheses in
science arise is a good one and a hard
one it's a combination of
psychology and sociology and science
right you know where does creativity
come from for that matter
um I don't think you know when you say
an attempt to be original that sort of
uh there's a positive valence to that in
a negative valence you're not going to
propose a theory that's not original
because someone already proposed it
right it's not that it's not a good idea
but they've already proposed that one so
it's not that you're attempting to be
original but you're attempting to get to
the truth and maybe the ideas that
currently exist maybe none of them is
the truth so you want to be original in
the sense that you're proposing a new
idea that has some non-zero chance of
being true that's a perfectly valid
motivation to have when you're doing
these
um as to why you pick the specific
hypotheses to look at yeah physical
intuition has to come into it and again
it goes back to what at least Mullen and
I discussed and I just talked about
right now
um different in Simon Deo and I
discussed different people bring
different intuitions to the table or
different commitments to different
precious principles right
one of the great things about Lee smolen
is he's more upfront about what his
most important principles are I don't
agree with his principles but they're
his principles and he's clear about them
which I think is a good thing to be in
terms of assigning Credence to theories
that are not testable
I don't know I mean I I don't think
that's a very good philosophy of science
attitude to have you know we're we
should be bayesians we should say
we assign priors to different hypotheses
about the universe based on whatever
criteria it is that we use to assign
priors and priors need not be
universally shared you're entitled to
your own priors but not to your own
likelihoods different people value
different things differently Simplicity
fruitfulness comprehensiveness and those
will affect their priors but then we all
agree on how the priors are updated when
we get new evidence we try our best to
say where the likelihood of that
evidence would be under the different
theories assigned to the priors and we
move forward from there but the evidence
can take on different forms sometimes it
will be experimental data sometimes
you'll be new theoretical insights
sometimes you'll be realizing that oh
this theory is actually more complicated
or more vague than I thought right that
counts as new evidence that you can use
to update your priors so that's why I'd
like to think about
um thinking about evaluating theories
rather than just saying this very very
crude idea this is testable this is not
it's more complicated than that
Eli Graham says priority question it
seems to me that quantum physics and the
philosophical movement of phenomenology
hussarel Heidegger merlopanti Etc
appeared and developed at about the same
time in the same intellectual climate do
you think quantum physics and
phenomenology influenced each other
so when I first read the question of my
answer that I was tempted to give was
nope they did not
uh at least in the direction of
phenomenology in this sense of
Continental philosophy phenomenology
influencing quantum mechanics what
influenced quantum mechanics was
black body radiation and you know the
spectrum of the hydrogen atom and things
like that but that would have been bad
I'm glad I didn't just give that answer
because the true answer is I don't know
and in fact it's perfectly possible that
there was influence uh in in either
direction and I just don't know the
history of it well enough but um you
know I did realize I did I forget
whether I've said this on the podcast
but I did amusingly I think I tweeted it
I was for some weird reason reading
about taoism
and one of the one of the web pages I
was reading about it mentioned that
Niels Bohr uh was knighted or got you
got some sort of
uh honor in Denmark and as a result he
got to design his own coat of arms and
he decided to in his coat of arms
include the yin yang symbol because he
was thinking about complementarity in
quantum mechanics right particles versus
Waves or position versus momenta
two things that cannot be simultaneously
described at the same time but are both
different aspects of the same underlying
thing the point of all that is that
um these people were highly educated
right this is this is back when the
center of physics was still in Europe
not in the United States and these
people all had philosophy educations
different levels of sophistication but
nevertheless it would not be at all
impossible to imagine that ideas being
put forward by the philosophers of the
time did seep into the space of
possibilities that were being considered
to explain the data by physicists so I
don't know what the answer actually is
but I'm willing to imagine that there
was a connection there
Anonymous says are you optimistic or
pessimistic that the USA and the world
will meet the required greenhouse gas
reduction Targets in time
if pessimistic do you sometimes think
about whether you as a smart person with
a large Network and a large audience
could do more to steer it in the right
direction EG with your choice of guests
or the question you ask
Etc
um so I'm pessimistic that we're going
to reach our required greenhouse gas
reduction targets uh you know it it's
very the the the track record is not
encouraging right I mean some
governments are into it some are not
those governments change with times you
can never predict 10 years from now what
different countries are going to be
doing
um however then you ask you know could I
do more to steer it in the right
direction well it's hard like if I
really thought that there was something
I could do fairly straightforwardly that
I would have a noticeable effect on the
direction of the world and climate
change then I would do it
um and we've had people talking on the
podcast about climate change Naomi
reskis Michael Mann rames Nam
um but I suspect that in terms of the
question we should do something or we
shouldn't I suspect I'm mostly preaching
to the converted here right I suspect
that most people not all but most people
listening to this podcast appreciate the
importance of the dangers of climate
change and the importance of doing
something about it I mean it it makes me
think about
authors with Twitter accounts and I know
that I'm one of them but you know when
an author uh has a new book out they
can't help but on their Twitter account
just talking about their book all the
time and I get it they're trying to
reach new people and make them buy the
book The problem is they're reaching the
same people over and over again they're
not reaching a new new set of people
with every tweet likewise with me and
the podcast you know I have my audience
but it's the same audience every time I
say this thing saying it more and more
often reaches a point of diminishing
returns very strongly and honestly what
is it that people can do to
um help with climate change like I've
said this before in here in the United
States which is the conditions I know
best the single most effective thing you
can do to help fight climate change is
uh get Democrats elected into office we
have strong political part polarization
in this country where if party a takes a
position party B reflexively takes the
opposite position and Democrats roughly
speaking on the side of trying to do
something about climate change and
Republicans roughly speaking are not
that's much more and you know any
individual person can't do that much on
those directions either but it's more
than you know recycling or turning off
your light bulbs or even driving an
electric car is likely to do I think
that these are problems that require
systematic Solutions not valorous
individual choices and the way that the
systematic Solutions are going to be
implemented is through governments get a
government in place that wants to solve
the problem and then you know once
that's done then you can tweak it right
like even if a government is more even
if a political party
is more devoted than the opposition
party it still doesn't mean they're as
devoted as they should be so you can
still try to pressure them once they're
in office
okay Charles Hertz says priority
question
one of the touted benefits of the
concept of inflation cosmological
inflation not economic inflation is that
it solves The Horizon problem I know
some people like Roger Penrose don't
believe in inflation and I think that
you've said in the past you're 50 50 on
it suppose that evidence empirical or
theoretical is found to clearly to your
satisfaction completely discredits the
concept of inflation can you speculate
on what other kinds of processes or
events might then need to be brought
into play to solve the Horizon problem
um that's a very good question and the
short answer is no I don't have any good
second option right
um and you know I don't like the horizon
or flatness problem that's something
maybe you can talk about on the podcast
I had blogged about it before I don't
the early universe is in a finely tuned
State compared to our natural
expectations of what it might be that is
a statement that I agree with but how to
characterize what the fine-tuning is I
don't think that neither the horizon or
the flatness problems are very good ways
of doing that as I've written about
before
um but it is fine-tuned and the universe
is smooth at Early times that's really
the problem why is it smooth inflation
would make it smooth if it began and my
problem with inflation is I don't know
why it ever began in the first place but
whatever thing caused inflation maybe to
begin whether it's some feature of the
wave function of the universe some
quantum gravity thing or some other
dynamical mechanism maybe he could have
skipped the step of leading to inflation
and just giving us a big smooth universe
that when I say big I mean like a
centimeter across when you take our
observable universe and you extrapolate
it back in time it reaches the the
expansion rate was the Planck scale if
there's no inflation the expansion rate
was the playing scale or let me say it
this way when the expansion rate was the
playing scale the size of our currently
observable universe was about a
centimeter across or a millimeter or
something like that and the problem is
even though that seems small for our
whole observable universe it's an
enormously big size compared to any
particle physics length scale like the
plank scale or the proton mass or
whatever so that's why I say make a big
universe that is smooth I mean a
centimeter sized universe that's one of
the wonderful things about inflation is
that you could plausibly begin the
universe a plank size across
and then inflate it up to be a
centimeter across and make our universe
that way
um but we don't know if it's true or not
so and I don't even have any second uh
favorite option
Sandro stooki says my question is about
Mock's principle I've heard it stated as
something like the large-scale
distribution of mass influences your
rotation flame rotation reference frame
or mass out there influences inertia
here these don't make sense to me it
seems to me that even if there were no
stars and planets out there I could
still feel the difference between myself
spending and remaining at rest so Sandra
I'm here to help you because I know the
answer to this one uh Mock's principle
is wrong
that's the answer Mock's principle and
you know you're not uh at fault for
having heard it stated in different ways
because mock never was very clear about
it and other people tried to make up
statements that would be a principle
that more or less corresponded to his
ideas and they were never completely in
agreement but it was an inspiration for
Einstein when he was inventing general
relativity the whole idea that there was
a relationship between matter and energy
in the universe
and space-time in the universe okay that
was the very general idea that helped
him go all the way to general relativity
in which the curvature of space-time is
influenced by matter and energy but the
actual idea that the reference frame
that counts as rotating versus
non-rotating for example is somehow set
by matter far away is just not part of
general relativity once you're at
general relativity you don't need Mock's
principle anymore like you like you're
intuiting here or implying there are
solutions in general relativity without
matter in them at all
and yet there is still a difference
between rotating and not rotating so
forget about Mock's principle it was
historically interesting it's no longer
relevant to Modern physics
okay I have two questions about Free
Will and the block universe
Siddhartha says our libertarian Free
Will and a block Universe mutually
exclusive we can have we can only have
libertarian free will if the future is
yet to be determined while in a block
Universe the future is already set in
stone are these ideas compatible
Redbeard says what distinguishes the
block Universe from someone at the end
of time with a knowledge of History I
ask because one has nothing to say about
fate or free will and the other has been
interpreted to preclude Free Will is
there a philosophical difference between
me knowing my history at the end of my
life and the block Universe view of my
life
um so of course I'm going to interpret
both of these questions I was asking
about libertarian Free Will which is the
idea that uh we human beings are not
completely subject to the law of physics
to the laws of physics somewhat we are
our centers of mass are subject to laws
of physics but our choices made in our
brains are not and I think this is a
silly idea I think that we are subject
to laws of physics and in fact I'm not
at all sure what the idea even means
um as I've said before in other contexts
if
a human being was found to be behaving
in some way that was clearly in
violation of the laws of physics what I
would do is change my idea what the laws
of physics were and then I would come up
with some better laws of physics that
included that human behavior I wouldn't
just say oh there are no laws that can
explain this laws might involve
probabilities or whatever but I'm
honestly not sure
how to even Define what might be meant
by libertarian free will in a way that
would make it a sensible notion that you
could oppose to
laws of physics based universes okay
having said all that
um I think that most conceptions of Free
Will are mutually exclusive with the
block Universe
um the block Universe comes about well
you know okay it's going to depend on
what you mean by a block Universe
um
oh yeah it is going to depend on what
you mean by a block Universe at all I
mean the original idea of the block
Universe was in a deterministic context
okay so it was really where you thought
that you could be laplace's demon know
everything about the universe now and
from that extrapolate what would be in
the future so Siddhartha you as you you
said in the in the I might not have read
this correctly but you said in the
question the future is already set in
probabilistic stone
you can't say that it set in stone means
it's deterministic you can't be set in
probabilistic stone okay so usually the
block Universe idea uh goes hand in hand
with being truly deterministic there are
there's subtleties there like if you're
a many worlds person
the wave function of the universe
evolves deterministically but
um the apparent Evolution that is
actually observed by individual
observers is not deterministic so you
have to finesse it a little bit it's not
a blocked Universe with a single space
time it's a block wave function it's a
single wave function that is that is
determined there
um but anyway if there are laws of
physics probabilistic or not
um then there's not libertarian Free
Will libertarian Free Will is the
ability to violate the laws of physics
so those ideas are mutually incompatible
um
to Redbeard's question someone at the
end of time with knowledge of History
I'm not quite sure what the relevance of
a person at the end of time with
knowledge has anything to do with it
um
the idea of the blocked Universe really
uh it matters that the future of the
block is in some sense inherent implicit
in what is going on right now so the
block universe is more than thus just
the idea that you wait infinitely long
and then you get a universe okay like
everyone agrees with that like even if
you're not a block Universe person if
you're a presentist you can believe that
you know you wait until the end of time
if that's a sensible concept and then
you say what happened you you write a
history book The Block Universe idea is
really like I said it goes hand in hand
with the idea that the future is
implicit in the present and in in that
case you don't need to know about what
the future is going to be
um and it's a case that is distinguished
from cases where either you have
indeterministic laws of physics or you
don't have laws of physics at all
because you have libertarian Free Will
in those cases the future is not fixed
in terms of the present and so the block
Universe idea doesn't quite fit as well
even if a person at the end of time
would have all the knowledge of it
okay not quite sure I did a very good
job explaining those things but
hopefully the the essence came through
alas poor Yorick says the connections
between physics and philosophy are
fascinating and yet it feels to me
fairly crucial to a scientific
temperament sorry and it feels to me
fairly crucial to a scientific
temperament yet my physicist colleagues
seem to relish a wholesale rejection of
the entire broad tradition of philosophy
I'm often trying to get these friends to
take philosophy Beyond a vague
impression of Carl popper and politics
other than naive techno technocracy
seriously I was wondering if you had any
thoughts on where this antagonism comes
from and how to counter it as it seems
quite pervasive and popular among famous
scientists who should know better
yeah you know I think this is a good
question especially because it doesn't
seem so number one I agree that there is
broadly speaking some hostility in
physics circles to philosophy in some
very that's a very overly simplistic
statement but there's some truth to it
but it doesn't seem to be constant over
time right as I just said a hundred
years ago uh the people who you would
identify as the leading physicist of
their generation were deeply in
interested in philosophy and philosophy
questions and they they would have
thought it bizarre to think otherwise
certainly in the past if you go to
boltzmann or Maxwell much less Newton
and Galileo and LaPlace these people
could barely see the difference between
physics and philosophy right so it's a
somewhat recent phenomenon
and it's not entirely wrong to co-locate
the Phenomenon with the transition of
the center of the world of physics from
Europe to the United States
so there is a cheap but maybe somewhat
uh relevant fact that Americans have a
different attitude about these things
than Europeans did Americans are more
direct pragmatic gung-ho get it done
don't ask too many questions
um and and that is an attitude that
actually fits very comfortably into
modern physics right which is kind of
ironic the idea because you know
physicists think about weird things
uh wave functions of the universe super
strings the Multiverse whatever but
given that subject matter physicists
tend to be pretty down to earth about it
you know they want to know what is the
payoff what is you know if you're
familiar with pragmatism right this
American philosophical tradition of
pragmatism which not exactly accurately
but but to give you some of the flavor
of it is sometimes acquainted with the
notion of the cash value of idea is the
pragmatist vision of truth of an idea
was what usefulness does it have in the
bigger picture purpose that I have so if
your bigger picture purpose is
predicting the outcomes of physics
experiments
and your view of Truth is essentially
pragmatic what is the cash value of
these ideas then you can see how you
would be
pointed in the direction of ignoring
philosophical questions to the extent
those philosophical questions didn't
help you predict the outcomes of physics
experiments now I don't know if this is
actually historically accurate I don't
know how valid this is as an explanation
for the hostility of modern physics to
philosophy but maybe it has part to do
with it
um how to counter it you know
part of it is there's a whole nother
thing going on which goes back to our
discussion of intellectualism
which is that there is a difference
between being devoted to a particular
field of intellectual inquiry and being
devoted to intellectual inquiry for its
own sake right just like there's a
difference in politics or in society
between be there's a difference between
being devoted to making sure that your
group gets the rights and privileges
that it should be afforded versus being
devoted to the idea that all groups
should get the rights and privileges
that they should be afforded right
um and in the case of intellectual
effort again it's perfectly valid either
way you know you can get a lot of
progress just by being narrow-minded and
sticking or at least narrowly focused
let me put it that way and sticking to
the interests of your sub-discipline and
so the other thing to keep in mind is
not America versus Europe and physics
and philosophy but just the hyper
specialization of the academy right as
knowledge has grown
to be influential and productive as a
knowledge producer requires increasing
specialization
and so
being appreciative of the perspectives
and values and techniques of other
fields is generally becoming devalued
right and it's not just physics and
philosophy that you pick out other
subfields just as well
so you know when I say this and by the
way you should take everything I say in
these in these discussions with a grain
of salt because I have a dog in the
fight I am very very devoted to
interdisciplinary discussions I am very
very frustrated by the fact that the
rest of the academy does not share my
interest in these things all the time
many
administrators or whatever talk a good
game when it comes to interdisciplinary
engagement but the way that we do the
organization of universities in the
modern world is Department by department
and departments are self-perpetuating
you know the
promotes the hiring and promotion of new
professors is at the 98 level done by
the professors in a department that
already exists
so you can say oh wouldn't it be nice to
hire someone who crossed over
departments but it's really hard to do
in practice and this
leads to the increasing siloization of
the academy and so that's a whole other
thing that probably feeds into this but
look everything I'm just saying right
now is vague anecdotal speculation these
kinds of questions are hard and to do
them seriously you have to do some real
work in uh I don't know history
sociology of Academia and that is not my
area of expertise I'm afraid
um sorry the other part of the question
was how to persuade them to think
otherwise you know there's two angles to
take you know one sorry point zero is
um is it worth trying to persuade them
that philosophy is interesting or useful
just like people on the other side of a
political divide or any other
uh highly polarized divide you first
have to decide whether the person you're
talking to is open-minded if they're
just devoted to their position then
don't waste your time right but there I
think there are a lot of people who are
dismissed of a philosophy or other areas
of intellectual inquiry more generally
who just don't know anything about them
but might be open-minded if they did so
then the two points I wanted to make
about that are number one
point out that
um
there are some tiny parts of
physics where philosophy is important
but point two uh
most of physics and most of philosophy
are separate but nevertheless valid so
in other words it is simultaneously true
that if you're doing something like
thinking about the measurement problem
in quantum mechanics thinking about the
role of probability and cosmology
thinking about the origin of the arrow
of time these are very very valid
obviously interesting physics problems
for which philosophy has a lot to say
and philosophy really is useful at the
same time there are plenty of physics
problems for which philosophy is not
useful that's just obvious and so
there's like no necessary connection
between physics and philosophy if you
want to calculate a Feynman diagram you
don't call a philosopher and at the same
time there's a lot of philosophy
questions that have no impact on physics
morality ethics Aesthetics right they're
intrinsically interesting in their own
right so even though I want to stand up
for the usefulness of philosophy to
certain
circumscribed parts of physics that's
not why I think philosophy is
interesting philosophy is interesting
because philosophy is interesting just
like physics is interesting because
physics is interesting that's the
attitude that I would mostly push on uh
but there are other people who are going
to be more persuaded by the fact that oh
if you want to understand that the
nature of entropy in the arrow of time
you better talk to some philosophers
because they have been more clear-headed
about those questions than physicists
have traditionally and recently
Frederick clutch clock loritz says
I've heard you mentioned that many
worlds doesn't have any philosophical
implications I think what you mean is
moral or ethical implications but I get
it uh how about a case where a person is
given the choice to sacrifice themselves
to save Humanity if the person believes
that this universe is all there is they
would be inclined to sacrifice
themselves because the alternative is
the end of humanity in a final and
absolute sense
but if they knew that there was a near
amount of other worlds where Humanity
would continue on then the person
wouldn't have to worry as much about
destroying Humanity because this is just
one world out of many
well so I think that doesn't work there
is as I said in something deeply hidden
elsewhere there is a version of Morality
In which many worlds does matter
um it's basically sort of a non-linear
version of morality if you don't care
about the average value of things but
you put an an absolute value on things
like if you put an absolute value just
on if you were a utilitarian for example
sorry no utilitarianism doesn't work uh
what works
um if you think there are some things
that could happen that would be sort of
absolute evils so evil that it didn't
matter if no matter how many other good
things happen so it's the opposite of
being a utilitarian if there are certain
things that you never ever ever ever
want to occur
um
then
you would try in the many worlds
interpretation not just to make them
unlikely but to make them sort of
impossible in any world right am I
getting that right I don't think I'm
saying this very very correctly but the
point is I can imagine cooking up
very sort of artificial sounding
versions of moral codes that would that
would in fact be influenced by
um many worlds oh yes I remember okay
yes sorry I'm getting the example wrong
here's the example that I came up with
in in something deeply hidden imagine
that your highest value was equality
in other words you don't care how rich
people are and we're just going to use
money as a proxy for Value in this case
you don't care how rich people are what
you care about is that they're all
equally Rich right
and then someone comes up to you and
proposes a thought experiment no propose
a real experiment uh they're a
multi-trillionaire very very wealthy and
they say We'll measure a spin of a
particle and if it's spin up I will give
every human being a dollar
and if it's spin down I will give every
human being two dollars okay now in the
ordinary quantum mechanics you would say
sure take that I would I would I would
let you do that I get either a dollar or
two dollars and so does everyone else
everyone benefits
um if you were a utilitarian and you
believed in many worlds then you would
also say yeah sure you know in one world
everyone gets a dollar and everyone in
the other world everyone gets two
dollars all good
but if for some reason you had this
cockamami moral theory that says that
inequality is intrinsically bad even
across the Multiverse
then you would say it's bad that in some
part of the Multiverse people get one
dollar and in the other part they get
two dollars and therefore I will not let
you do this experiment at all and
everyone gets zero dollars that keeps
them equal right
okay that's a very very silly moral code
I think but it is an example of how in
principle uh many worlds could matter
now I don't think that works for the
example that you're giving
um in this sort of given the choice to
sacrifice themselves to save Humanity so
I mean you didn't phrase the way the the
thought experiment in a way the quantum
mechanics has anything to do with it so
if you're just given if someone holds a
gun to your head and says you know I
have a trigger that will destroy the
universe and either you let me kill you
or I do the trigger and everyone dies
you know by the way if everyone dies why
not just sacrifice yourself if I don't
see the you know you're not getting
Advantage out of this for not
sacrificing yourselves
um but okay let's say that you were sort
of cowardly and didn't want to do that
there's no Quantum in there there's no
branches of the wave function in there
there's one branch and in that Branch
you will either
save the humanity or not okay so what
you need to imagine is that there's some
probability
that some Quantum probability that the
universe is sacrificed right so would
you sacrifice yourself
to give the population of the earth a 50
chance of dying or being saved versus
not sacrificing sorry yeah I think the
right way to do it is if you sacrifice
yourself there's a hundred percent
chance that no one dies if you don't
sacrifice yourself there's a 50 chance
that everyone dies right and a 50 chance
they don't because then you can actually
have something to weigh against the
different occurrences in different
branches of the wave function so
um
but in that case I would argue you know
just as I argued in in the book it's the
the analysis is exactly like a single
World in which there's just a
probability of it right so
for me and maybe not for other people
depending on your moral code but for me
there is no difference
between a scenario in which there's a
branch of the wave function in which
everyone lives and an equally sizable
branch in which everyone dies and a 50
50 chance uh in a single world of
everyone living in anyone dying so
that's a vivid difference
conceptually but I think it doesn't make
any difference to me actually in in you
know the actions I would take uh to save
the world because for exactly the reason
that if you're going to be if you're
going to believe in many worlds
then you believe that four people living
in that Universe their experiences are
exactly the same as people who live in a
single Universe where these things
happen with a certain probability okay
so it's it's very much like the quantum
suicide experiment where you say well
you know if I die in a certain Branch I
don't know I only experience life in the
branches where I'm alive
that's not valid analysis in my mind
because as we said before in a different
context right now before the experiment
is carried out I care whether I'm going
to survive or not if there were a
classical world and someone says you
know would you mind if some if you were
killed instantly and uh painlessly I'd
say yes and the fact that I won't be
around to regret it is completely beside
the point I would regret right now the
the prospect of no longer existing and
that's just as true in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics now
others might disagree okay so again this
is stuff where it requires thought
because the metaphysics of of writing
quantum mechanics is very different than
our usual way of thinking so by all
means uh think hard about this I'm not
going to say that I've given you the
final answer but that is how I think
about it
Hilbert Spaceman says what would
constitute experimental evidence that
Schrodinger's equation does not always
hold for example why isn't every
measurement of a spin evidence of this
well the answer why every spin
measurement is not evidence of that is
that in many worlds
Schrodinger's equation does always hold
and yet it predicts exactly what we see
in spin measurements right so clearly by
itself that is not evidence what it's
evidence for is that in our branch of
the wave function we cannot explain what
happens by assuming uh the the that we
see the whole result of the Schrodinger
equation holding we're only seeing part
of the result but what you would need
for evidence that Schrodinger's equation
doesn't hold is to see wave functions
violate the Schrodinger equation without
being observed right without being
measured without being de-cohered
without becoming entangled with the rest
of the world when we in the real world
do a measurement we entangle things with
the rest of the world
you can do experiments where you wait
for things to violate the Schrodinger
equation even though they're not being
observed and you know if a wave function
spontaneously localizes that would have
experimental impacts energy would not be
conserved in a very obvious way for
example so you know you need to be
careful that you're not secretly
disturbing the system but that's always
going to be the case when you're trying
to do a careful physics experiment you
need to be careful
Fred Alexander says would you consider
allowing one of your patreon members to
interview you for a mindscape episode
um
I would consider it I'm not sure you
know uh what I what I would make me
pause about that is not that it's not an
interesting idea but I'm not sure if it
distinguishes itself from what we're
doing right now with the amas right like
in the amas in some sense
you're getting an interview of me from
100 different patreon members each
asking one question each so I'm not sure
there's that a lot of value added to
that plus there would be setup involved
but again like many other things I have
enormous appreciation for the patreon
supporters here if there is a huge well
of support for an idea like that I would
take it seriously let's put it that way
DMI says doesn't the re schleider
theorem resolve the black hole
information paradox
and there's a longer if you want to go
to the website and and go to patreon and
look at the um
question being asked there's a much
longer explanation of what he means by
that the re-slider theorem is basically
just the idea that well it's stated in a
particularly Fantastical sounding way
but what it comes down to is the fact
that in a Quantum field Theory every
little bit of a Quantum field in one
location of space shares some amount of
entanglement even if it's a very tiny
amount with a bit of the quantum field
in the vacuum State this is all for the
vacuum State at any other point in space
so you pick two points in space take a
small region around them a cubic
centimeter or whatever there are Fields
inside them and it is a feature of the
quantum vacuum state that they are
entangled maybe only a little bit of
entanglement but there's some
entanglement between those Quantum
fields and as a result of that the
richlider theorem says if I
project onto the field in one region of
space in exactly the right way
I can turn the rest of the wave function
of the universe into essentially
whatever I want okay now that's a little
bit misleading because of the verbs in
there don't actually correspond to
things you're actually allowed to do so
if I have to make things simpler just
take a single particle right which is
spin up plus spin down an electron that
is in a superposition of spin up and
spin down and I measure the spin
what happens when I measure the spin is
uh
there's a probability I will see it spin
up and a probability I will see it spin
down and after I can describe that by
saying I projected onto the spin up part
or the spin down part the problem is
that you can't ahead of time decide
which thing to do in other words if your
electron is in a superposition of spin
up and spin down you can't say ahead of
time I'm going to measure it and get
spin up
if you could then you could do super
luminal communication between Alice and
Bob having entangled particles right I
mean I think this is the thing that
people implicitly suspect you can do
when they think that entanglement leads
to superluminal communication if Alice
and Bob have two particles and they're
entangled in opposite directions so
they're anti-parallel then the correct
thing to say is Alice measures her spin
it's either up or down Bob measures his
spin it's either up or down they're
correlated if one is up the other is
down but they don't know neither one of
them know the answer that the other one
got right
if Alice was able to measure her spin in
a way that guaranteed that she could get
spin up
then Bob could measure his Spin and he
would always get spinned down and if he
did that with 100 spins he would go aha
they're all spin down Alice is sending
me a message right but Alice can't do
that so typically they'll get 50 50 on
both of them
um so likewise
in the reach lighter theorem there is
something that can happen in the cubic
centimeter of space that you look at
that in principle if that thing happened
would cause the rest of the state of the
universe to change an incredibly
dramatic way
it the the example it's often given is
you could make the Taj Mahal appear on
the moon okay but you can't force it to
happen you can't choose to make that
happen there is a thing that could make
that happen but it's incredibly
extraordinarily super duper unlikely
that's why these things don't ever
happen in the real world Okay so
the question about resolving the black
hole information Paradox if I I tried
DMI to understand the your longer
version of the question but maybe like
everyone else I'm misunderstanding it
um the reach lighter theorem implies
that there is entanglement between
degrees of freedom inside the black hole
and degrees of freedom outside the black
hole that's true
but that doesn't help you get
information out right that's the point
the point is you want to get the
information about the quantum state of
systems uh out of the black hole and if
you just believe the most naive version
of what happens in space-time
the part of the quantum state that is
inside the black hole hits the
singularity and disappears
and when you're left with outside is a
mixed Quantum state that has just had
the information about what fell in
erased right it's the equivalent of you
know Alice falls into the black hole Bob
has a spin and after Alice Falls in and
the black hole evaporates
Bob's spin is 50 up and 50 down but the
exact entanglement with Alice's uh spin
is just lost forever so that's the
information loss puzzle so reach lighter
relies on the fact that there's
entanglement but that's not nearly
enough to help you get the information
out roughly speaking
Rebecca lashua says
on the internal inflation Wikipedia page
it says the inflationary phase of the
universe's expansion lasts forever
throughout most of the universe does
that mean that some finite distance from
the earth there's a patch of space-time
undergoing exponentially fast expansion
or the parts of the universe undergoing
inflation disconnected from our universe
in some way uh yeah usually you know
Eternal inflation is not perfectly well
understood so there's details and
different versions of the scenario but
roughly speaking the idea is that yes
some finite distance away from the earth
there should be a patch of space-time
undergoing exponentially fast expansion
in fact
in most versions of this most of the
volume of the universe is undergoing
exponentially fast expansion uh in in
Eternal inflation if Eternal inflation
is happening at all
um they are usually outside our causal
Horizon so it's not that they're
disconnected physically but we can never
get there you know we could never get
there even if we started the speed of
light and move right now
Gillis 15 says although the events were
detected by ligo and Virgo in 2020 a new
paper just released confirms for the
first time a black hole neutron star
merger would black hole be able to tear
apart the neutron stars the star
spiraled in or with the neutron star
cross the Event Horizon whole so this is
an interesting astrophysical question
and I'm I'm addressing it not because I
know the answer not this is a little bit
too down to earth uh for me but I think
that part of the excitement of this my
impression from reading the popular
articles about this particular event
is that we learned something about this
particular question you know
it's complicated neutron stars are messy
black holes are non-linear and and
there's a lot going on and Einstein's
equations are hard so you might guess
that it's plausible either way that the
neutron stars mostly swallowed whole or
that it is gradually torn apart
if you are really good at doing
simulations you should be able to make a
prediction ahead of time but I don't
know what the state of the art of those
simulations is
um it seems from what I understand the
fact that we didn't see an
electromagnetic counterpart of these
particular events implies that to a very
good approximation the neutron star was
swallowed whole and if you see little
pictures little animations that they
made that's basically what happens the
neutron star comes very close to the
black hole and then disappears very
quickly so I think that's what happens
but I don't know if that's always what's
going to happen or if this was
particular to the cases of these
particular in spirals again I'm not
enough of an expert to know
naive Bayesian says how would a good
Bayesian reconcile the following
hypotheses number one reality is real
number two reality appears real because
Descartes demonstricking you three
reality appears real because you're a
boltzmann brain four reality peers real
because you're in a brain simulation
five reality appears real because of
literally any other ad hoc tomfoolery
example
um so you can't
you can't really reconcile those but you
have to deal with them in some way so I
think that
um I mean there is a a strategy that
more or less works but I'm not going to
pretend that this is a situation where
all the eyes are dotted in the teaser
crossed that I understand exactly what's
going on or at least have a good set of
advice to give you so for those of you
who are not you know familiar with all
these different phrases here
um this is the idea that either the
reality you see around us is basically
real
there really is a desk in front of me a
microphone a computer and so forth or
that somehow we're in what we call a
skeptical scenario somehow that there is
a kind of reality
that is very different than the apparent
reality around us but you are being fed
in illusion okay so this is different so
there's a subtle difference I want to
emphasize the difference between
something like the difference between
the Manifest image of the world and the
scientific image of the world so the
fact that there's a table in front of me
and a microphone Etc
none of this none of these words table
microphone appear in the standard model
of particle physics
this the whole classical world I see
around me is a very tiny slice of the
real world if you believe in the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
so those are both senses in which
there's a difference between reality and
what you see but in both cases that's
just because you're seeing a small part
of reality and you're still seeing part
of reality what you're seeing is part of
reality even though it's not all of it
okay that's not what's being talked
about here what's being talked about
here is the idea that there's reality
and there's what you see and they're
very different because you're being
misled or tricked in some way and so
it's not that hard going back to
Descartes who is a master of this
um it's not that hard to imagine
skeptical scenarios that are so
convincing that no experiment you could
do would reveal that what you were
experiencing was not reality right maybe
a very good Demon is tricking you or
you're in a simulation or brain in a vat
or whatever
I think that's possible I think that is
a something that is on the table maybe
we are being tricked but as a good
Bayesian this is the question you're
asking what does a good Bayesian do in
this case
um
you have to discount it I mean I think a
good Bayesian says look if I can take
what I do observe
and explain it in a variety of different
ways and some of those are simple and
coherent and self-contained and others
are awkward and artificial and
complicated and weird I'm gonna pick the
simple ones I mean there's just no
X nothing added by imagining that we are
a boltzmann brain or a simulation or
being tricked by an evil demon
so I think that's the way to go in the
real world
um you want to make sense of the world
and so the way that I talked about it in
my paper on why boltzmann brains are bad
is that the
to to exclude the boltzmann brain
possibility by just setting the prior
Credence on it to a very very very low
number
Keeps Us in a cognitively stable
situation if you say I'm not a boltzmann
brain then you can make sense of the
world if you say well maybe I am a
boltzmann brain then you can't make
sense of the world because you have no
reason to trust any of your experiences
of the world so it's like it's not a
useful
hypothesis on which to put a lot of
credence that would be my argument now
having said that the the little niggling
problem that should worry you is
as a good Bayesian you should never set
your credences in any physically
possible scenario to exactly zero
because if you did
then no future evidence would enable you
to find that hypothesis you've set it to
zero and you multiply by zero every time
you update right
um so I do think good bayesians should
keep some non-zero Credence even for
these skeptical hypotheses what if the
demon reveals themselves and says huh I
was the demon who was tricking you right
then you want to be able to update and
go ah a demon was tricking me all along
so at the same time I think you want to
set these credences to very tiny numbers
but not to zero and how do you do that
what do you mean very tiny do you mean
one in a million one in ten to the
million I don't know I don't know what
those those things are fortunately I
don't think there's a lot of credence
for any of these scenarios so I don't
need to worry about it that much but I
appreciate the importance of this kind
of question in uh principle
Fabian rostollen says regarding it
regarding vegetarianism
you're the only person I've heard making
a reasonable argument for the
justification of eating animals namely
their lack of ability to anticipate
their future their mortality and so on
the philosopher who got me convinced of
veganism morally put for forth the name
the trait argumentation style of
reasoning about these issues namely that
if this trait if a certain trait or lack
thereof is sufficient for killing a
reading another being it should be so
regardless of the species of that being
example it's okay to eat animals because
they're not as intelligent as humans
should then also conclude in therefore
it is also okay to eat humans with equal
intelligence to an animal do you agree
with this reasoning if or if not why so
I don't really agree with this reasoning
but let me give a little stage setting
here first you know I am a moral
constructivist I think that what we call
morality
is sort of a systemization and
codification of our moral inclinations
of our of our deep-sitted feelings that
certain things feel right certain things
feel wrong plus our rationality uh the
idea that we would like to take these
feelings and systematize them into a set
of consistent principles right and
sometimes our inclinations might be
inconsistent incoherent and we have to
do some work like what do I really care
about and we might also want to talk to
other people and get more insight into
possible ways to be good and bad and
that would also change our minds so I
don't think there is a simple and direct
Road from our moral feelings to morality
as in moral philosophy but that is the
starting point
um and because of that
morality is not objective or cut and
dried or rigorous or uh Universal
different people might come up with
different kinds of morality so all that
is to say that the answers to these
kinds of questions might be different
from person to person rather than me
giving you the once and for all Final
Answer even in my own mind okay having
said that
um so in my mind when we come up with
rules like you shouldn't eat humans uh
or whatever the rules are you're coming
up with rules so you're inventing rules
to fit the inclinations you have and to
me it makes a hundred percent perfect
sense
to apply those rules on a species by
species basis rather than on an
individual by individual basis
decide to apply them on an individual by
individual basis that's a different set
of morality and then you and I could sit
down and talk about the implications of
that choice but it's not my choice and I
don't think it's the choice that most
people would have
um and which you know part of this is
why
even though I'm not vegan or vegetarian
myself I have 100 respect for people who
are as a more constructivist it would be
very it would be a little bit
hypocritical to me if I said well you're
just wrong you vegans right if you think
it's wrong to kill animals and eat them
I get it you know you're totally valid
in that
um if you think it's wrong that I kill
animals and eat them you know what I
even get that because I'm not a moral
relativist I don't think that everyone
or every society gets to make up their
morality I think it's perfectly valid to
do your best
to come up with moral rules and then
apply them to other people right I think
that because that's the perfectly even
if they're not going to come up with the
same rules the rules that you come up
with have you know are what you think is
moral and not moral so it's okay if you
judge me badly I get that
um I'm gonna try to uh well both of
course think through my own moral reason
and then also sit down and reason
together about what our Collective rules
should be about whether eating animals
should be legal or illegal and so forth
and hopefully we can have reasonable
conversations about that but I think
that this particular issue of you know
this assumption that or maybe not
assumption but claim
that it is somehow incoherent or
inconsistent to apply rules to species
rather than individuals is completely
arbitrary and ad hoc you know I'm
applying my rules I'm telling you what
my rules are I apply them species by
species and that seems perfectly
sensible as a thing for me to do
okay I'm grouping we're reaching the end
here but I'm grouping together a couple
of questions this is about faster than
light travel
so Moshe fader says the two largest and
most popular science fiction franchises
involving space travel Star Trek and
Star Wars share as part of their basic
premise the common science fiction
assumption that their methods of near
light speed and fashion light travel
somehow exempt them from relativistic
time dilation
so that got me worrying wondering about
wormholes if they could be made
traversable and you could use one to
cross the Galaxy and return with the
temporal effect of Relativity still
apply even though you had never moved
relativistic speeds
and then Damon Winston bird says I have
to go to Alpha Centauri and I don't want
to spend years getting there I hop in my
alcubi air Drive which is the kind of uh
warp drive solution to the equations of
general relativity invented by miguela
kubierre and get there in only one year
after taking care of business there I
hop into my faster and light out kubi
air drive and I'm home again after
another year of travel time did two
years pass on Earth as I traveled
so these are slightly different
scenarios wormholes versus warp drive uh
in the Wormhole case is actually a
little bit more straightforward but the
it's more visualizable or
conceptualizable let me say it that way
but the answers are the same in both
cases in both cases
you're effectively moving faster than
the speed of light
why do I say effectively because locally
you're not right in both the warp drive
case the iqb air warp drive case and in
the Wormhole case what you're really
doing is stretching space time warping
space time in such a way
actually interestingly what you're doing
in the lqb Air Sports warp drive is
literally warping space-time around you
even though the idea
far post dates the phrase warp drive so
I wonder I have no idea why warp drive
is called warp drive I think just
because it sounds cool and fast but the
idea that you get it by actually warping
space time uh is is probably not what
they had in mind but it actually fits
very well anyway
um in both cases you're looking at a
space-time curvature setup okay a
geometry of space time that is different
than just flat space time that you get
in special relativity and this lets you
and and you've done it in a specific way
that you can compare
two different ways of traveling between
two points in space one way is by just
going in what you might think of as a
conventional path
right not being in the warp drive not
being in the Wormhole and then it takes
you a certain number of years to get
where you're going certain number of
years to get back from the point of view
the people who stayed home
or you can get there to the same point
by traveling through this tunnel in
space-time either in the warp drive or
in the wormhole
so the question is
forget about time dilation that's not
really quite the right way to think
about it the question is how much time
elapses in your reference frame
according to your clock
as you are traveling between this point
and this other point either in the
Wormhole or in the warp drive
and the answer is I don't know the
answer is it depends on the details of
the Wormhole or the warp drive so it is
completely plausible that they're
synchronized in such a way plausible
maybe an exaggeration conceivable is a
better word maybe so in the when the
warp drive is a little bit fuzzier again
but the Wormhole is a pretty direct
thing there's a distance you travel
Through the Wormhole okay there's a
distance you travel back and there's
also a time that it takes to go in the
Wormhole and a time it takes to come
back and I could easily imagine setting
up my completely fictitious Wormhole
system such that uh the time that
elapsed on my watch as I travel Through
the Wormhole and travel back
is the same amount of time as a lapse to
the people back home okay
um and presumably I could do the same
thing with the warp drive although I
haven't actually gone through the
equations in that case
um so in other words
I think it is completely
conceivable to set up a system of
effective faster than light travel that
works like Star Trek and Star Wars do
that that actually in the back of
everyone's minds they haven't quite
graduated from Newtonian absolute
space-time to relativity and they think
that there is something called the
simultaneous things going on on Alderaan
and Tatooine or whatever and that's the
narrative frame of reference of the
movie okay
um you could imagine something like that
it's not what would naturally pop out of
a realistic space-time geometry but you
could imagine it so you know you want to
make movies go ahead all of these are
really uh cowboy movies at the end of
the day
you know when you say you're in a
Starship really you're in a covered
wagon going far away and and that's how
they really think about things this is
the right way to conceptualize why they
have the adventures that they do okay
Anonymous asks in episode number 62 with
Kate Jeffrey you both talked about how
physicists are essentially certain that
the Universe won't last forever and
about how some of the processes that
will cause the universe to wind down
you also talked in general about how
ironic it is when knowledge about
physics stays stuck in Ivory Towers when
the explicit purpose of studying physics
is to discover new knowledge for society
I'm curious about how the knowledge that
the universe will definitely permanently
end has impacted society and culture or
whether that's an example of something
the public really ought to know more
about so just to be super clear
the sense in which I think it's pretty
clear it's never definitive never 100 so
I don't want to say that but it's
overwhelmingly likely that the universe
will end is not that time will end
it's that the ability of the universe to
increase an entropy will end right
there's a sort of limit about what we
can do as we travel from low entropy to
high entropy there's only so far we can
go as you can illustrate by the way in a
mindscape t-shirt we have a t-shirt
showing the curve of entropy versus time
as well as complexity versus time it's
not the most physically accurate graph I
just drew it in the in a little program
but he gets the idea across anyway
um
so it's not the time we'll end with the
arrow of time will end we'll use up the
fuel that we have to keep the universe
going that's what I was talking about
with Kate in that episode and with
another Kate with Katie Mack we talked
about different physical ways the actual
Universe might end which is a slightly
different concept
but um it's an interesting question you
ask about whether or not this idea of
the heat death of the universe that's
really what Kate Jeffrey and I were
talking about the running out of entropy
um does that have an impact on society
well you know because it did when it
came about right when people first
started talking about this
um in the late 19th century early 20th
century it did leak into the popular
imagination and I'm I'm gonna get it
wrong I want to say Henry Adams talked
about it
um and other people who are not
physicists you know they caught on to
this I mean arguably Nietzsche in his
idea of Eternal recurrence was at least
indirectly affected by this discussion
going on in physics before they knew
about the big bang and things like that
um and Thomas pension more recently uh
has absolutely written about related
Concepts
but okay
um it's still not there in the everyday
life of popular culture we don't talk
about it too much and maybe
it's just because people don't care I
mean we're talking a very very long time
scale and uh uh you know Zach
wienersmith the cartoonist uh was
talking on Twitter just today because
he's writing a book on future space
travel and he says one of the things
that is frustrating about talking to the
real gung-ho Space Geeks is that the
time scales of interest to Ordinary
People Into The Space Geeks are very
different so when Zach will say look all
this talk about terraforming planets
it's just unrealistic we shouldn't worry
about that this is not on the horizon
and the Space Geeks are like no no it's
completely plausible we'll absolutely do
it implicitly Zach is thinking within
the next Century or two and the space
keeps Geeks are thinking within the next
million years or two right and so that
difference in implicit time scale
matters a lot real people have
difficulty thinking even 100 years in
the future So when you say that the sun
will burn out in 5 billion years and the
last star will turn out in a quadrillion
years and the last black hole will
evaporate into Google years
they're not their lives are not affected
by that very much they they are amused
for a minute and they go back to their
everyday lives and you know what they're
not wrong I think it's an interesting
thing to think about but I'm not really
sure that has a huge impact on how we
should live our lives here on Earth
lineumizara says what would physics look
like today if Feynman hadn't invented
his diagrams
um well there's two answers to that one
is uh it would look the same because uh
someone else would have invented them I
mean Feynman diagrams are great but like
most other inventions in theoretical
physics someone gets there first but
other people would have gotten there
eventually so I think it's
overwhelmingly likely that someone would
have invented diagrams filament diagrams
it's just too too juicy too useful too
helpful and and this is like drawing
diagrams uh so they someone would have
invented them eventually maybe we'd be
calling them Weinberg diagrams or a
touch diagrams or something like that
whiten diagrams but the other answer the
other version of the answer is maybe
this is the implicit thing what if
nobody had invented Feynman diagrams I
think that somebody would have but what
if they hadn't
um you know Julian schwenger who shared
the Nobel Prize with Feynman and
topanaga
basically did the same calculations that
Feynman did without the diagrams
and famously you know the joke was that
because they were kind of Rivals
schwinger refused to use Feynman
diagrams uh for the rest of his career I
think that's not true I think he did
actually use diagrams uh but he had a
way of doing the same calculations
purely algebraically purely with
equations right so you can imagine a
world in which we did the same
calculations but it took longer they
were harder to do because they were a
lot more difficult math and the
conceptual Clarity wasn't there
maybe there's a different kind of
conceptual Clarity that would have been
there since we wouldn't be as stuck with
visualizing particles literally moving
on lines which is what we were invited
to do when we think about things in
terms of finding diagrams even though
it's really the quantum fields that are
going on so I don't know if there would
have been very big differences in how
physicists think about the world
um but anyway I do think of the diagrams
we're going to come at one point or
another
Richard cashdan says suppose I ask a
priority question today and then during
the next month I run the universe
splitter app a bigly number of times to
pretty much guarantee that I end up on a
different timeline Can I submit another
priority question next month uh no you
cannot because I don't know what do you
mean end up on a different timeline you
know if you ask a priority question
today
then all the future versions of you are
ones that descended from someone who
asked a priority question today you
can't undo the past by making
measurements with the universe splitter
or any other quantum mechanical uh
measurement process sorry about that if
you could I'd be writing papers about
that that'd be a very important thing
okay the very last question this has
been a long one today
Lewis B says how sure are we the things
like Hawking radiation are literally
true are likely true my understanding is
that the prediction of Hawking radiation
rests on both quantum mechanics and
general relativity being useful
approximations in the vicinity of a
black holes Event Horizon but isn't the
entire problem those theories don't play
well together in particular in regimes
precisely like a black hole where if
anywhere would you no longer trust these
theories to be useful
so again there's sort of a narrow
version of this question and a broader
one the narrow version is do we have
good reasons to trust general relativity
and Quantum field theory in the event
horizon of a black hole and the answer
is yes so
you you're saying you know aren't black
holes exactly where we should not trust
Quantum field Theory or general
relativity but that's not quite true
um The Singularity near in the in the
future when you get into a black hole
that's where you shouldn't trust general
relativity the general relativity says
all the equations are blowing up the
curvature is infinite I have no reason
to trust things anymore
but near the Event Horizon the curvature
of space-time can be small especially
for a big black hole so that's precisely
a regime in which you should trust
general relativity perfectly and in fact
here's the here's the um
they're quite you know the tiny reason
why you might be skeptical of that
argument I just gave so the argument I
just gave was based on the idea that
general relativity becomes untrustworthy
when the curvature of space-time becomes
large and that's actually not true near
the eventualized of a black hole the
curvature of space-time can be small
um
in Quantum field Theory there's an
analogous statement when do you trust
Quantum field Theory well when it's
close to the vacuum State locally and
you only have a few a small number of
particles and again near the Event
Horizon of a black hole you should be
able to trust Quantum field Theory it's
nearly the vacuum if you fell into the
black hole you wouldn't even notice
unless there are firewalls or something
like that in which case all bets are off
but let's assume that there are not
the problem with what I just said
is exactly the black hole information
loss puzzle namely
that both general relativity and Quantum
field Theory by All rights should be
trustworthy near the Event Horizon of a
black hole but taken together they lead
to the information laws puzzle and so
that leads many people to say that
somehow in a subtle way
one of them is wrong near the Event
Horizon of a black hole probably Quantum
field theory in some subtle way right
there's some kind of non-locality that
allows information to be transferred out
of the outgoing Event Horizon
um but so even if that's true we think
that if you looked at a black hole
the even if you think that information
gets out in the radiation you wouldn't
be able to tell whether radiation is
getting out just by looking at it what
you'd be doing is saying that the black
hole is really analogous to classically
setting a book on fire right if you
classically just set a book on fire let
it burn in principle all of the
information in the book is contained in
the outgoing heat and light and Ash and
dust and so forth but you can't tell by
looking at it right you can't recover
what was in the book once it's burning
that would be the case if you could
actually look at a evaporating black
hole you would see the Hawking radiation
in principle all the information is
there but in practice it just looks like
a black body you can't get it out okay
um so that's what we expect to have
happen now the other aspect of your
question that I wanted to raise here is
in principle in general in other
circumstances
how much confidence should we have in
our theories when they are being
extrapolated into regimes far beyond
where we've actually tested them
this is a very good question and a very
hard one and I don't have a good answer
for you
um
if it weren't for
black hole information laws we'd be
really pretty confident in Quantum field
theory in a wide variety of
circumstances and we think that black
hole information loss is special because
gravity is so important in that case so
in practice we are pretty confident in
Quantum field theory in cases where
gravity is not nearly black hole
strength okay that's why I can say that
the laws of physics underlying everyday
life are very well understood right now
because we live in an environment which
where there's no black holes nearby so
the usual reasons why we trust Quantum
field Theory are likely to be valid
maybe not and then this is again
something that we need to be uh
cognizant of
um
I think personally that the
extrapolations we do of known laws of
physics are extremely likely to work
when we get to black holes because
um
you know there's nothing that breaks
down the things that seem to break down
are things that we
see exactly what is breaking down the
information getting out right and in
other cases in other uh context other
questions we want to ask about it it
seems perfectly benign but then there
are other cases where we're
extrapolating like into the early
universe
and there people are a little bit
sanguine I think about talking about
ideas like inflation
um or bariogenesis or other things that
rely on extrapolations Far Beyond well
we've tested in a laboratory because
they're often not simply relying on
robust features of quantum field Theory
but they're relying on specific features
of specific Quantum field theories and
those I don't have much faith in at all
when we're extrapolating them to the
very very early universe so
I think that in general you know the
physics that we've currently established
is so good that we do become a little
complacent about extrapolating it into
regimes that we haven't explicitly
tested yet and we should be a little bit
more humble about that that doesn't mean
we all things go and anything can go and
we shouldn't have any faith at all we
should have a Credence that we should
keep under control and the Credence
might be large but it's not a hundred
percent so this issue of where in
general we should thank our current
favorite theories are valid there or
they're applicable the domain of
applicability of a theory that's a good
one that I think both physicists and
philosophers should think harder about
we haven't really nailed that one down
which makes it the perfect question to
end on something we don't know the
answer to there you go okay that was a
lot of words thank you for sticking with
me here thanks for asking the questions
thank you for supporting the mindscape
podcast I really do appreciate it come
back with more questions next month bye
bye
[Music]